Okay,
and we live these gentlemen,
we're live supporting the latest round
earth Shell.
We're just coming out with it.
Round Earth.
She'll tee shirts.
Both Jamie and I get $3 per month from
the federal government to tell you that
the world is round and Mick West is a
big part of it all.
He is one of the main shills that tells
everybody that he knows that he has a
whole website dedicated to arguing
against people that think the world is
flat.
Yeah.
The differences that don't get paid for
it.
And stop lying.
I know you're getting 3:50
per month.
Yeah,
I wish I did.
I would have to pay for my web hosting
and it's a command in my pocket and
nobody pays me anything.
See,
Mick West is serious.
He's not joking around with us.
Um,
what this is to be one of the most
bizarre trends.
And Jamie,
I think you said at first that you
thought it was originally a troll.
You thought that they were fucking
around,
like,
I still think some people are for sure.
It's.
Yeah,
but I feel like it started out with like
four Chan or something like that,
or maybe you read it,
these crazy kids,
these wacky kids,
they decided to start trolling saying
that the earth is round or the earth is
flat.
Some of it.
But a lot of it is just people who,
uh,
yeah,
they,
they actually believe it.
Yes.
There's a lot of extra people actually
believe it.
And then there's people who see that
this people out there who believe it and
then they start like kind of egging
these people on.
Yes.
And then it becomes really,
really hard to tell where the dividing
line is,
who's actually trawling and who's
actually a genuine,
true believer.
There are absolutely a lot of true
believers,
but there's also a lot of people with
like little green frogs in their avatar
that think it's fucking hilarious.
Yeah,
I think it's the kind of,
uh,
that type of person that's kind of uh,
adopted it.
Yes.
Yes,
yes.
Uh,
you know,
you talking a shit posting the other.
Yes.
And that's just something that you could
do is if you want to just annoy people,
buy shit posting,
you'll just post a bunch of flood earth
memes because the so infuriating to the
average person.
But I just kind of a what the heck is
this person is posting and uh,
you know,
the shit poster enjoys that type of
thing.
I was watching a video with this guy was
ranting on and on,
and then it's not theory that we need to
stop accepting that the flat earth
theory,
but that it's a fact.
We need to start accepting the fact that
it's a effect.
He was hilarious when we find this
because I saved.
It is a,
I think his name was like Vegan warrior
or something like that.
Which is always a yes.
The Egan Warrior.
He's a realist.
It says it's no long.
He's not only a flat earth or he's a
realist.
Yeah,
I think I've come across.
I think this is actually a relatively
small number of people who were really
active in promoting the flood of stuff
on,
on Youtube.
What's in the world is that they
keep claiming that all the photos of
earth are fake,
but they don't have a single photo of
this fucking ice wall that's supposed to
be around Antarctica and they keep
saying erroneous Lee,
that you're not allowed to fly over
Antarctica.
Like,
yes you are.
They keep saying that there's no
photographs of earth from space that
they're all composites.
No,
that's not true.
Why do they keep saying that?
They keep saying that there's a fucking
saddle is a bunch of satellites,
but there's one from Japan that takes
high resolution photos of the earth
every 10 minutes.
The full earth from 22,000
miles away.
Yeah,
that's the Japanese hemaware.
Yes.
But there's also like a,
as a US satellite that was just launched
last year that goes 16 satellite,
which is basically the same resolution.
Pull this sucker right up to your face.
And the Russians,
the Russians have a satellite,
a.
everyone's got their own satellite
because he's basically the way that
satellites.
So they put him like,
uh,
oh,
the equator so they can see their own,
uh,
their own country.
So Russia has one,
you can mostly see India,
China has one,
it's not as good as the other ones,
but the Russian one is there like a,
you know,
the same resolution,
121 megapixels as the size of the image
that I do.
It's like a 11,000
pixels by 11,000
pixels view of the earth and you can
zoom in and you can,
you can see cities,
you can see contrary cells and you can
actually use these images from the
satellites to actually match up with the
views of clouds and controls from the
ground.
So you can actually check to see if
these images are actually correct,
at least for where you are.
Right.
Then you could like finding friends and
somewhere else and ask them like,
do you have this type of cloud overhead
so you can actually verify whether
these,
uh,
these images are actually real on it.
Well I brought it up to my friend Eddie
and he said it's all fake.
He said all the photos of fake,
they look fake.
I'm like,
but how would you know what a real photo
of earth from 22,000
miles looked like?
Wouldn't look exactly like earth.
And I think when you get to that stage
of deep belief,
you kind of have to believe that they're
fake.
There's no way,
a real challenge.
Like how do you actually break through
that for somebody?
How can you actually,
um,
convince them that something isn't fake
if they just automatically assume it's
fake.
And I think has,
has the person actually looked in detail
at these images,
most people know and how they looked at
the fact that,
you know,
you get one every 10 minutes.
I went every 15 minutes and do a,
you know,
every single images is 121 megapixel
image and the old matches up exactly
with what the weather is around the
world and it matches up with all the
other side images.
One from the Russians were on from the
Chinese run from the Japanese.
Uh,
they all match up.
And I really don't think that the people
who say,
ah spake,
I've really actually looked.
No,
you're absolutely right there.
They definitely haven't,
nor nor do they have any desire to.
It's a belief issue and it's almost like
a religious issue.
It's a really fascinating.
It's completely infected.
The world of professional pool players,
really professional pool player,
a professional pool players.
There's a guy named cj Wiley's,
a top pool player who's 100 percent
convinced the earth is flat.
There's another guy named Max everly's.
A buddy of mine out of his mind thinks
the world is flat.
I wonder if that's related to their like
obsession with the table being flat.
No,
I don't think so.
You'd have to make sure that the
temple's level,
but then they got this little round
balls on the table as well,
so that's confusing,
right?
Yeah.
You got a little solar system going on
with your pool balls.
What's confusing is they're smart guys
like you.
We talked to them.
You'd be like,
this is a reasonable intelligent guy.
Are they really believing that his blood
100 percent,
they're not shit posting jewel.
This unusual people,
they go down a youtube rabbit hole and
that's part of the problem is once you
believe something,
yeah,
it's very difficult to unbelievers.
It is and there's so much out there.
Yeah.
If you tell people to do some research
or the end up doing is just looking at
more videos,
the confirm what they.
They believe that they prefer the ones
that come from it of course,
but it's just amazing to me that people
would decide that all of these photos
were fake so that they don't believe the
world is round,
but yet they don't have a single photo
of this fucking flat earth.
Not One one photo.
Not only that,
every planet you see is round.
You can.
You could follow them.
You could look at them with with if you
have a reasonable telescope,
you could see the difference as the
change and spin.
I mean you can tell that they're round.
There's a lot of flood earth.
Have the same camera that I've got,
which is a Nikon p 900 flat earthers
have an excellent camera.
They have A.
I brought one with me.
They have like Nikon has a deal with the
flat earth society.
Is this,
this camera?
It's just like,
it's not like an slr or anything.
It's just like a $600 camera,
uh,
but it's got this really,
really long a zoom lens on it,
like a,
it's like a 200 millimeter zoom lens so
you can see,
you can zoom in on the move and you can
zoom in on the stars and planets and you
can use this camera.
I've used it a few times to actually
take pictures of Jupiter and have a
Venus Mars and you can actually just
make out the roundness of the planet and
the actual shadow of the sun use.
You'll see Venus as being like the move
and being like an arch and you'll see
jupiter and you see the bands of Jupiter
and you can do that with this camera.
And this is a camera that a lot of them
have because they're obsessed with
zooming in on things that are on the
horizon,
like ships going beyond the horizon.
But if they just start,
take the same camera that they haven't
pointed upwards,
they would actually see things in the.
In the sea,
the solar system,
basically the rudy come be explained any
other way.
One great thing is the moons of Jupiter.
If you look up a Jupiter really closely,
even with some binoculars,
you can see it's got these four little
moons that are orbiting it.
Then it looks like to just follow the
lights in the line with with Jupiter and
they actually move around in a regular
pattern and they move around.
They've got all bits of like some of
them are thinking like 80 hours or
something.
So they move around really fast.
Like everyday is a completely different
pattern of these little dots around
Jupiter.
And you can actually see that with this
camera.
I've taken photos of it,
posted them on the website or even with
binoculars.
And if you actually watch it from day to
day,
you will see the moons of Jupiter move
in exactly the same way that science
predicts us that they should move.
Were you using Kepler's laws of
planetary motion and Newton's Newton's
law of gravitation?
Uh,
they will.
Yeah,
they,
they move exactly as if they are a
little simulation of a planetary system.
So either the,
some kind of weird hologram up in that
little corner of the sky which moves
around or there is actually a planet
there with little moons orbiting it.
Probably Hologram.
What,
what,
when did you first become aware of this?
Like you,
you've run medibank for a long time.
And for those who don't know,
Mick and I met on the Scifi show that it
did Joe Rogan questions,
everything where we discussed chem
trails or con trails and what causes a
jet engine to make what looks like
artificial clouds by passing through
condensation in the heat of the engine
produces these countries.
And people were absolutely convinced
that these are,
that they're spraying the government is
sprang something in the sky.
And uh,
you,
you caught it,
you had a fairly good explanation for
it.
You said they're basically like training
wheels for conspiracy theories because.
Yeah,
it's,
uh,
something you can see.
Yeah,
I think he's said he's kind of more
enticing.
Yes.
Uh,
and I think the same thing applies to
the flat earth.
Now you got some.
When I got into the flutter thing,
it was,
I became aware of it a few years ago.
So yeah.
So the government is turning up.
Is that your camera?
Yeah,
yeah,
the government spying on.
Yeah.
So like,
uh,
when I first heard about the flood of,
they obviously have,
I heard it before my actually my father
going back,
uh,
when I was young,
he told me that he was a member of the
flood to society.
Your father told you that was he joking
around?
A kind of,
but what he was doing it in a kind of a
satirical way.
Ironically,
uh,
he was doing it because like he was like
saying people,
uh,
to sure of themselves.
And so I'm going to join the flux of the
society.
He didn't believe the earth was round,
so it's been around for quite a while.
The flat Earth Society and the flesh,
the flusher theory,
uh,
as beat around obviously like thousands
of years ago,
people thought the earth was round and
then slightly fewer thousand years ago
people figured out that it wasn't,
it was figured out by the ancient Greeks
like 3000 years ago that it wasn't a um,
by the.
It wasn't that.
It wasn't,
it wasn't flat.
Sorry.
Oh,
you fucked it up.
You gave up the goose.
You,
you said thousands of years ago,
people thought the Earth was round and
they realized it wasn't you just right
now you gave them fuel.
That's a quote that's going to go on
youtube.
I am a,
she'll quote from the last one.
What do you strike that one?
A slight misquote.
Yeah.
So,
so yeah.
What happened was science basically
figured out the shape of the universe.
And you know,
in the,
uh,
the 18 hundreds,
there was a gentleman scientist doing
those courses.
All kinds of cool things with stars,
like measuring the orbits and checking
out how far away things were and
discovering that there were galaxies and
things like that.
You know,
there's all this science going on,
but then there was this kind of,
this guy comes along coal Samuel
Robotham who published under the name of
Parallax in 18,
60 and he started publishing what is
basically the same as Eric debase book
that's been published now pretty much
every single thing that Eric debase
current book you will find in Samuel
Rebirth book from 1860.
And in fact,
if you read the book,
which I don't recommend,
uh,
you will see that about 80 percent of
the text book is actually quotes from
these books from the scene.
Hundreds.
It's not actually that this new stuff
that he's discovered is all stuff like,
you know,
if somebody walks away from you,
you will see their feet disappeared
first.
And then he has a two page quotes of
Samuel wrote both them saying the exact
same thing from the 18 sixties.
So it's basically recycling this,
this theory that started in the 1860
[inaudible] and then just adding a few
little sprinkles to it.
Like,
you know,
saying that as astronauts must be fake
and the space station is space.
Satellites are fake as well.
Yeah,
he's hilarious.
He thinks that dinosaurs are fake
nuclear bombs or fake.
I mean there's the idea that one person
will be this mastermind that discovers
all these monumental frauds.
Yeah.
And he,
he,
I don't think he's claiming to discover
these things.
There's lots of people who think that
newco nukes are fake and you know,
dinosaurs being fake.
It's an obvious thing for creationists
and people of that ilk.
But uh,
yeah,
he's,
he's basically recycling theories in a
way that is popular to the reader and
figuring out how to get them across to
people.
So he,
right.
It is the youtube videos that are very
engaging and they sound good.
They sound,
if you don't know what's,
what they sound like,
they make sense.
That's the problem.
And some of them are quite technical,
but at least they use a lot of technical
terms.
But the,
the,
the delve into things like,
um,
uh,
there's,
there's a variety of experiments.
The Michelson Morley experiment,
the Eddie mentioned is one of them that
keeps cropping up and then there's the,
which has never been reproduced.
That's the experiment that actually has
been reproduced because it's the wrong
way,
not the way that they wanted the
Michelson.
Morley,
Missouri,
the Michelson Morley experiment was an
experiment to detect the luminaire
forests ether,
which is the supposedly medium through
which light travels.
Now back in the 18 hundreds,
we didn't know that the light was made
about a photons [inaudible] light was
was waived.
So we thought that there was this stuff
that permeated all a space called the
luminesce luminesce,
luminesce,
ether,
luminaire ether.
It's a little hard to pronounce and that
this is what light travels through as
waves going through and didn't know
exactly how it works,
but the they figured that must be this
stuff that permeates all space.
And then they figured that since the
earth was moving and these scientists
actually knew at the time that the earth
was moving,
so they were using this as a basis for
their experiment.
They thought that if the earth is
moving,
then they will be able to detect the
ether by doing these experiments.
So what they did,
they set up this experiment where they
shot light one direction and the shorter
the other direction.
Then when it came back together,
it combined and if they were moving
through the ether or if the ether was
moving through them,
then the light that went one way would
interfere with the,
with the light and went the other way.
So that was the,
the whole experiment was just just this
thing.
They shot these two light beams in two
directions and they figured like,
you know,
if we turned the table this way,
it will change because we're now going
through the ether in different
direction.
But what happened was nothing was
detected,
which was kind of the start of people
realizing,
oh,
there is no luminary.
Ether use that to say that is because
the earth isn't moving.
That was what the flatter.
But they did.
They did.
The Michelson and Morley knew the earth
was moving.
They wanted to figure out whether the
ether was moving with the earth or
whether the earth was moving through the
ether.
So they were trying to detect the ether.
So people who thought that the earth was
the center of the universe,
not really so much pellet,
flat earthers people who are Geo
Centrists,
people who thought that the sun went
around the earth and the whole all the
stars went around the earth and there's
still people like the recent resurgence
of some of the thing was Gavin mcinnes
sent me something or some guy thinks
that the earth is the center of the
universe.
Essentially.
He was saying that it sort of confirms
everything in Genesis.
I was like,
what?
Yeah,
well,
I mean if you need to shoehorn a whole
universe into the descriptions in
genesis,
then he probably gonna have to take a
few.
A few shortcuts.
They,
yeah.
This,
these,
these experiments like the Michelson
Morley experiment and.
But people bring them up and they say
that what the detector,
it was no motion,
but what it actually detects your
detective was no luminaire for as ether.
And because they detected no luminary,
luminary burst ether,
they eventually led to theories about
what light actually is,
which is a wave particle duality.
You know,
the light is photons which act both as a
wave and a particle and eventually to
the theory of relativity.
Well,
you started medibank when,
when did you,
uh,
I think it's about five years ago,
but I've been doing the chem trail stuff
with control science for like over 10
years now.
I was just looking at one of my old
posts when a satellite images that's
quite surprised at how long I've been
doing it.
Uh,
and uh,
yeah.
And medibank been going about five years
and the flat earth stuff came up maybe
two years ago.
I started to see things about flutter
earth and a
little bit over a year ago I wrote a
post on what,
what should we do about debunking the
flat earth?
And it basically said like,
all these people are basically either
trolling all the crazy.
So there's no point in addressing either
of them.
And I think most of them are just
trolling because no one could seriously
believed this.
You'd have to be like,
I don't think you're right.
I know I've come to realize that I'm
not.
I was wrong.
And that,
that post,
now it's gone down the line,
but it's,
it's,
you know,
I've always been one a from that.
It's stunning.
It really is stunning.
It's stunning how many people like this
is why Jamie made these young Jamie.com.
You can go and get these flatters shell
shirts that uh,
somehow or another were being paid to
say that the earth is round.
Like the idea that anybody would
actually believe that I've had so many
people tweet at me.
I know where your checks to come in
from,
Bro.
You're fucking sell out.
I'm a sell out.
Like why would I give,
do you don't think that if I really
thought the earth was flat,
like if someone thought the earth was
flat,
what a revelation that would be.
What an amazing discovery P,
every scientist will be clamoring to
expose this.
Every single scientist,
the idea that all these scientists who
make their name off discoveries by the
way,
especially a monumental and provable
discovery,
like the world being flat like somehow
or another,
they would hide that.
And then the big question is why would
the government say the world is flat?
I mean,
why would they in any way,
why would they rather hide the fact the
world is flat?
Like what?
What motivation would anybody have to
show that the world was round who've
been pretty fascinating.
If we lived on this flat disc and
everybody else throughout the universe
was in a on a planet,
we'd be like,
Whoa,
what's this?
What's going on?
And there's a weird thing that's going
on with some of these flat earth people
where they're linking this to assign
that we are in some way special that we
are the chosen ones.
And that was,
you know,
in some it keeps going back to genesis
and that you know,
that we are the children of God and that
creation is true.
And that evolution is a lie.
And it gets to some weird anti juice
stuff with a lot of these guys.
Yeah.
A lot of conspiracy theories basically
boiled down to some kind of suspicion of
other people.
And quite often suspicions of Jewish
people.
Why Jewish people was always the Jews.
It's just people couldn't catch a break.
I didn't know exactly why.
I think perhaps perhaps because of the,
the whole,
uh,
the Jews killed Jesus Christians don't
let the Jews or Christians don't like
the Jews.
Yeah.
So the just being viewed as being an
other and they're often near the Jewish.
Uh,
the broader us population is often like
a minority within sitters.
So it's an easy person to pick on when
things go wrong about that way.
I'm sure there's loads of books written
by Jews,
other subject of conspiracy theorists.
Do Bay have a recent video about Jews
and about Hitler.
They all,
they all go down that road.
Um,
what,
what can it be done if anything other
than your website?
What can be done,
if anything to like
my,
my concern is these young kids that are
on the fence,
my thoughts are I'm not going to reach
out.
There's some 45 year old crazy person
who is making youtube videos three times
a day about the world being flat and
ranting and raving and challenging
everyone to debates that he's never
gonna engage in that.
Those guys don't mean anything to me
like you can't do anything about them,
but there's some 16 year old kids out
there that maybe were in highschool and
maybe don't have a real formal education
in science or astrophysics and they're
getting confused and they may be smoke a
little too much pot as you motherfucker
whoever's listening to this.
That's you and you start.
It's.
I've,
I've been tricked before and I wrote
this big instagram posts recently about
Rod's about those roswell rods.
God,
they got me.
I was convinced.
I was convinced,
but it was just.
I never looked into it.
I just watched a documentary and this
guy had the footage.
I was like,
wow,
these things are flying around and we
can't see them.
That's crazy.
Yeah,
and then a show called [inaudible] if
you don't,
if you'd never saw the instagram posts
that I made.
There was a guy that made this video,
a documentary.
I think you made more than one and it
showed that there was these things that
looked like tubes that had jelly fish,
like wings that were flying through the
air.
Supposedly it speeds undetectable to the
human eye,
like they were moving so fast we
couldn't see them and so I was convinced
man I was really good and then there was
a show called monster quest and what
they did is they set up two cameras,
one camera which was a very fast high
speed camera,
and the other one which is a standard
video camera and the standard video
camera caught all these rods flying
around and then the exact same images
right next to each other with this high
definition,
high speed camera showed actual bugs.
So what those rods were was just a video
artifact of these bugs that we're moving
so close to the screen and so fast that
the camera couldn't register correctly
and so it created this elongating effect
and made it look like there were these
jellies.
Fish.
Yeah.
Well,
I think that type of thing,
that type of video is the type of thing
that needs to be done to counteract this
type of
work though,
because if people aren't looking at the
of eight,
if they see those images,
I put those images up and dude,
if you look at them,
my instagram posts,
it's filled with people angry at me
because they think it's fake.
They think it's fake.
I don't think I'm a shill because I put
that up.
If you can't get people to look at
things that that's a challenge in
itself.
How do you get people to look at things,
but I think like if you start slowly,
I do.
I engage with a lot of like conspiracy
theorists online and I know when I'm
doing it I'm not actually going to reach
the vast majority of the people.
I'm talking directly to that.
I know there's lots of other people
reading what I'm saying.
Who,
who will and you know,
just because people are complaining
about your posts of the create images
doesn't mean that there aren't people
who actually went to look.
Ditto.
Oh,
I'm sure.
Because I think it got like 50,000
likes or something like that.
So I'm sure even besides people that
didn't like it,
many people there were like,
Oh really?
Like is because that was one of the big
things that they,
the flat earth people kept saying that
there's no photos of the earth that
aren't a composite from space.
Like that's just not true.
And they're like this,
this Rod's video that you saw with the
two cameras.
If that hadn't existed,
you might have taken a bit longer.
Yes to.
I mean,
you might still believe it now.
You might be telling your friends about
it.
Have you checked seeing these crazy rods
that are everywhere.
The guy who made that video showed up at
a q and a that I did once for the UFC.
I do these q and a's where people yell
out questions like,
what do you think about this guy?
That guy,
that kind of thing.
And uh,
he waited in line to get to the front of
the line to tell me that I was wrong or
that the rods are reelected,
like,
come on,
you still buying it.
You're still,
he still selling it,
they call it,
they call them roswell rods.
Just hilarious,
but they're implying that somehow or
another they're alien.
Probably some guy was at Rosewell taking
pictures,
trying to get you fos and some bugs flew
by.
It wasn't even Rosewell.
That's what's funny.
They called Roswell Rod.
The best footage is from Mexico.
The best footage was from a bunch of
cave jumpers.
You know they have that one really
enormous cave,
but it's a.
it's a whole essentially a gigantic pit
and people skydive into it.
I've ever seen that.
Yeah,
I've seen things like that.
It's pretty wild.
But they filmed,
they set up a camera to watch them jump
off the edge and parachute down and you
see the rods flying by.
That was like the best footage was from
Mexico,
from this one place,
so it had nothing to do with Roswell.
They just called them roswell rods
because they're dorks.
They probably had to,
you know,
they were probably looking down the
darkness of the pit below and then they
had a shaft of sunlight and friends of
that.
So the books are flying through the
sunlight with a dark background,
which is something you don't normally
see.
So it would have been like an unusually
good environment for rods to show up in.
Exactly,
exactly.
And it's in that guy,
me waiting in line to get to the front
of the line.
They asked me a question and tell me
that,
you know,
he has the evidence,
I need to see it.
It's that kind of thinking is once
someone commits to an idea,
it's very difficult to shake them off of
it and they just look for confirmation
bias.
They just look for someone else to agree
with them.
They find communities,
they find these flat earth communities,
which is hilarious.
The flat one of the best.
One of the best fucking unintentional
hilarious things I read online.
This dude wrote the flat Earth Society
has members all around the globe.
Yeah.
Whoops.
Did he even realized what he was saying
or is that just him fucking.
I hope it's trolling.
Yeah,
because the community thing I think is
like a key thing.
Yes.
I,
I just,
I recently did a deep bond of a Ufo that
the Chilean navy supposedly saw a,
what was that?
I'm not aware of that way.
It was,
it was like this.
I'm just thinking that it was a Chilean
navy helicopter had this infrared camera
and they sold this,
this black to black dots off in the
distance that looked like a weird thing,
like a,
like a figure eight type thing flying
away.
And then it started like spraying out
this stuff and they couldn't figure out
what was.
And they chased after
it,
but it was too fascinating going away
from them.
Uh,
and the Chilean government has an
official UFL investigation team and
they,
they set them on it and spent two years
figuring out what it was and they
couldn't figure out what it was.
And they said it's a,
it's a,
uh,
confirmed unidentified object.
Uh,
and then they published their findings
and then I,
and some other people and medibank
looked at it and we figured out that it
was actually just a,
a plane flying away from the helicopter,
leaving some controls behind.
We actually figured out exactly what,
which plane it was a and so this got
this,
got a bit of play online and there was
unlike Huffington post and things like
that and some Ufo enthusiastic,
a study talking to me and I joined the
groups and I joined a few of the groups
and then I find myself in this kind of
weird corner of the Internet where
everybody believes in Ufo shows,
unquestioningly and they're always
putting up these photographs of things
and people are like,
oh,
great capture dude.
And it's just something like a street
light or something.
But uh,
they,
they think they had this,
this confirmation bias,
this group confirmation bias where they
can't disagree with someone and they
know they're in a safe space.
So they can put out whatever theory that
they like and they know that people will
be like,
they're just very supportive of them.
By one that happened a couple of days
ago,
some woman put up a picture of a strange
light that she said was in the sky.
And so I downloaded the picture and I
boosted the brightness.
And a story was actually a reflection of
a something in a security light on her
porch and you could see it was like it
was trees behind it and it's a security
license is reflection.
So I posted that and then I started
getting cold,
like a shill for pointing this out.
A couple of people.
I said,
Oh yeah,
it's just this life.
But other people were like,
well,
why don't you believe me?
Why you would like invalidating claims?
And so they want to have these kind of
walled gardens where everybody believes
the same thing.
That's a good way to put it.
Walled Gardens,
it really is a good way to put it
because that debt is what those
community seemed like.
And that's one of the things that I
found when I did that television show.
I.
I still harbored a few conspiracy
theories before I did that show,
but doing that show for several months
and constantly interviewing people who
believed in outlandish things.
I found the same thing over and over and
over again.
Illogical people with very little
evidence,
believing things in almost a religious
way.
And I found it with bigfoot and I found
it with us and I found it with chem
trails and I found it with.
It was just one after the other in
varying stages of ridiculousness.
Feel like contrail chem trails where the
most nutty people,
Ufo people seem to be the most
reasonable because it's the most
reasonable theory at of all of them.
The idea that we have spaceships.
Why doesn't someone else have
spaceships?
There's hundreds of of galaxies in the
known universe,
hundreds of billions of planets in each
galaxy.
The odds of there being some sort of a
life form out there.
It's pretty high,
but there's nothing.
That's the craziest thing.
Like the more I went into,
the more I talk to these people,
the more I went over all their evidence,
air quotes,
evidence,
the more I asked them why they believe
things.
There is nothing.
There's not a goddamn thing that you can
put on a scale.
There's nothing that you can way.
There's not a thing that you can
measure.
There's not a thing that you can look at
a photo and go,
wow,
that's compelling.
There's not one,
they just an idea and that idea is that
there's something in this guy that flies
around that we either might catch if
you're there,
the right place,
the right time or not,
and that they're from another planet.
Yeah.
I could look at what they put forward as
the best evidence is often like snuffing
cases from the six days where there's an
eyewitness who said something like,
there was some guy on a road who says he
blacked out and like,
you know,
his car got messed up from the sixties.
Well,
that's the other thing that I know too
much about psychedelic drugs and I know
about indogenous psychedelic drugs.
The brain producing this chemical called
dimethyltryptamine.
That happens when you're sleeping.
Now they've proven that this stuff is
produced in the liver and the lungs and
they believe it's now.
They've got evidence that it's produced
in the pineal gland is a very potent
psychedelic drugs that your brain
produces and your brain produces during
rem sleep.
So these people,
they all take naps and during these naps
they have these crazy fucking dreams and
it's entirely possible that during these
dreams what happened is they got some
indogenous dmt dump,
whether they were under stress or
whether they just add just a,
an erratic dump of this human
neurochemical that entered into their
bloodstream.
Whatever it is,
it caused it all these fucking Ufo
abductions,
all of them,
like almost exactly happened at night.
And they happen when these people are
sleeping.
Like,
wouldn't you just assume that you are
dreaming?
Like why?
Why wouldn't you assume you were
dreaming?
Yeah,
I,
uh,
I have these.
I used to have a night terror
hallucination things which are kind of
like that.
Yeah.
And it was always the same type of
thing.
It was like a giant spider coming down
from the ceiling to ultimately move.
I was frozen for a second and then jump
out of bed and turn on the light and
look for the spider.
And it happened all the time.
Like,
and I knew because there was no spider
that it wasn't real.
But I could see if someone was having a
different type of hallucination that
seemed a bit more real,
and then,
you know,
it may be,
it's a,
it came in between sleep cycles for them
then.
Yeah,
totally.
Yeah.
You can see because it seemed completely
real.
Yeah.
I had,
I used to have them all the time and it
was always like,
you know,
it was horrible.
It was these like giant really realistic
spider.
And it wasn't like I was dreaming
somewhere else.
I was in the room and I could see it
like I was seeing something crawling
across the table right here.
It was this hallucination.
I don't really get them any more than
what it was,
uh,
you know,
my brain is fixed itself or whatever,
but it's probably a lot.
Do it being young and confused and
hormones and nerves.
And then also
like your brain starts filling in the
blanks.
You don't have a very good understanding
of the universe in your brain.
Your imagination runs wild.
I,
it was very confusing to me doing that
television show and it really changed me
a lot and it changed me to the point
that people started accusing me of being
a co opted by the government that the
government threatened my family and told
me to stop talking about conspiracies
like and then the idea that I wouldn't
say that if that was the case,
like you don't think I would fucking
tell everybody if someone threatened my
family because it was talking about
Ufos,
I'd be telling everybody I'd be like,
hey man,
I would tell all my friends.
I'd be like,
dude,
they fucking threaten me because I was
talking about Ufo is this shit is real.
Hangar 18,
Harry 51.
There was a paper a while ago published
online how many people it would take to
cover up seven conspiracy theories and
the probability of none of those people
ever talking.
Yeah.
And it's just ridiculous.
Like you can't have tens of millions of
people in on a conspiracy.
Well,
the flat earth one is the best one for
that.
Yeah,
I mean that's.
What about those clients?
Every single scientist.
Yeah,
and everyone who is involved in shipping
routes and overseas flights and the fact
that you can fly west and land east,
I mean,
you,
you can,
you can just land in one spot,
take off again,
land in spot,
and you could eventually get to the same
spot that you're at with a bunch of
different flights that you can track
them on,
on a gps.
I mean,
it must fight to gps.
Oh,
that's everything is everything.
Yeah.
Well,
one thing I want to,
uh,
try to introduce two people who believe
in flat earth is this concept that a
ground truth,
a ground truth as a concept in a
satellite observations,
which I kind of touched on before.
Like you take a satellite observation
and you say,
does it match what you see on the
ground?
Or if he goes something like a weather
prediction model,
predicting the weather you see,
does that match what you see on the
ground?
And this is something that you can do if
you're actually really interested in
looking into the flight.
A theory is figure out what the actual
ground truth is.
Full something.
Now I want to talk very briefly about a
program called delirium,
which you might've might've seen.
It's just basically a solar system
simulates,
it,
shows what's in the night sky.
You've probably seen these little,
these little,
uh,
things on your phone where you hold it
up and it shows you what the stars are.
Yeah,
just went like that for the PC.
And you can use,
use the one on,
uh,
on your phone as well.
So what I would encourage people to do
is figure out what is this program
actually correct?
Is it actually showing me what we see in
the night sky?
And you can do it really easily.
Basically you just look at what's on the
screen and then you go outside and you
look to see,
is this what I'm seeing on the screen
here?
Uh,
so this is basically you checking the
ground truth of this program,
which seems like a very straightforward
thing,
but then what you can do from that is
you can then use the program to look at
the sky from other positions.
And
because you verify that it's correct for
where you are and you can ask someone
else to verify it's correct for where
they are and you can check like other
photographs that have been taken to see
if they match up as well.
You'll eventually build up,
you know the knowledge that this program
is correct.
This still arion program,
all the little program you have in your
phone that shows you the stars in the
sky.
So you've got this computer showing you
what it expects to see from any
position,
any position anywhere on the world and
you by doing ground truth observations
have figured out.
I figured out what it actually is.
Yeah.
So that's.
That's the type of thing you see in
delirium.
A obviously in a much less light
polluted environment than you have here.
Do you think that a lot of what's going
on with these people that are theorizing
and keep that up?
That's pretty cool.
Look at with a lot of what's going on
with these people theorizing about flat
earth and there seems to be some desire
that people have to expose hidden
truths,
hidden hidden discoveries or or things
that are somehow or another being kept
from everybody and the the.
What's,
what's fascinating to me is they're
looking into this nonsense.
They're looking into this thing that's
not real.
When the real space like the actual,
like what is observable about space is
so mind blowing.
Yeah.
And somehow or another that is what you
absolutely can see every day where you
absolutely can observe what you
absolutely can read about and learn
about and what scientists are
discovering on a daily basis is so mind
blowing when you see like they don't
believe satellites are real.
When you see how many satellites we
actually have,
that's what's really fucked.
It's not that there's no satellite.
Yeah.
Satellites bashing into each other and
then uh,
we'll have been more centralized there.
Thousands of them up there and they have
to time,
space flights.
They have to time space lights based on
whether or not they're going to hit
these satellites or space junk or some
of the stuff that's been ejected from
various rocket trips.
I mean,
it's still floating
up there.
You seen the movie gravity?
Yes.
Yeah.
This bit in that where the satellite
start bumping into each other and it's
this big chain reaction eventually.
All the satellites.
Good.
So I didn't get knocked out.
Did you see that Japanese express
expedition that they tried to.
Do they try to capture?
I don't know how well it worked that
well.
I had a really big tether.
They were dragging behind it.
Yeah.
They were trying to like catch a bunch
of space junk with a net,
right?
Yeah.
Somehow or another.
It's amazing.
Yeah.
This stuff is way more interesting than.
Yes.
Yeah.
That's the real stuff that's really
crazy with idea is so it's less.
These tiny little thing with the earth
is flat and it was stuck in this weird
prison where people are keeping us here.
Yeah.
That's the thing too,
that somehow or another,
by being on a flat planet,
it gives you a different perspective and
they don't want you to have that
perspective,
so they tell you the world is round like
it doesn't make any sense.
Yeah.
One thing I've heard is that they think
that if they can convince you that the
world is flat when it isn't,
then it's kind of like in 19 four where
they get people to believe that two plus
two equals five and they've actually
indoctrinate people to genuinely believe
that even though they know it's not
true,
but they still believe it and it's a way
of mind control,
said the same thing would have happened
with the flat earth,
but on a far grander scale,
you're not just convincing someone that
two plus two equals five and war equals
peace,
et Cetera,
et cetera.
You're convincing them that the earth is
flat when it's actually around.
So by doing,
by twisting their minds around something
that's demonstrably false and making
another thing that is correct,
then you're gaining power over their
minds in the same way that they did in
1984.
Right?
Well,
in the same way the scientologists do or
Mormons do or anybody that creates some
sort of an ideology that's provably
false.
I mean,
look,
there's not a whole lot of difference
between scientology and flatter theory.
I mean,
there really isn't.
I mean if you really read l Dot Ron
Hubbard's work,
if you read what his actual theories
were about the origins of mankind,
it's pretty fucking loony.
And yet there's thousands and thousands
of members of scientology to the point
where they're making documentaries about
it and writing books about it and these
people are coming out and they've
escaped the church and these harling
stories.
Man,
I had this guy on my podcast a couple of
weeks ago.
Ronnie miscavige is David miscavige's.
Dads want in the sky has been wasted his
life can.
I lived in the scientology world for 50
years.
I mean it's,
it's crazy.
It's crazy.
It is.
Not much difference between that and
flat earth theory.
It really isn't.
You know,
scientology works like it's like
gradually sucks you in a bit at a time,
you know,
it just sounds all very reasonable at
the.
It's very self help in the beginning.
More and more like the further you get
into it,
but also the reverse,
the first original principles of it.
Like when you start thinking positive
and doing positive things,
there's a lot of benefits to that and
people start seeing those benefits.
They start feeling positive and then
they get into the tetons and the frozen
souls chucked into the volcano and
they're like,
what?
Well,
I think you could
argue that the sim good in the flood
earth,
not the flat earth theory as such,
but the black death way of thinking like
questioning things.
And I think this is something that
people really like about it,
is that you don't,
you don't,
you don't believe scientists just
because scientists say something is this
thing they called the static method,
which basically is a Greek word meaning
questioning.
So you've got to question everything.
You can't believe that gravity exists or
pandemic around the scientist because
scientist do it.
You actually have to observe it for
yourself and if you can't absorb it for
yourself then it isn't real,
which leads people to think the earth is
flat because it kind of appears flat
from various positions and they haven't
been into space or they haven't done the
various experiments that show that is
not flat.
So I think you've got young people who
are exposed to the idea of as a techy
ism and they think,
oh,
that's great.
You know,
I've,
I'm rebelling against authority like
young people do and they think like,
I will not believe.
I will not believe the scientists.
I'll do my own research,
but then they get sucked into people
like Dubay who feed them all this
nonsense is very articulate and very
smooth the way he talks and he makes his
well edited videos and they're very
compelling.
And because he's not an authority,
he's not like,
you know,
part of the government.
He's perhaps the,
the,
the old culture.
They tend to give his arguments way more
weight than mainstream science.
Yeah.
And then they'll find out something like
that New York Times article that was out
a couple months back where it showed
that scientists from the 19 fifties were
paid off by sugar companies to switch
the blame to saturated fat and they
started attributing all these health
problems that were really about sugar
and about eating processed sugar start
attributed to the saturated fat and it
changed a lot of people's diets and
really fucked a lot of people up in
terms of like,
like people started eating margarine and
all these things that are filled the
trans fats and very unhealthy for you.
And they did it because they thought
that they were following science.
And so questioning science and
questioning scientists,
you know,
occasionally you're right,
occasionally you'll find something like
this.
Yeah.
This conspiracy by the sugar industry,
you know,
there's the old saying,
trust yet,
verify.
Yes.
Reagan popularized that with a salt
talks.
I think yes,
that's a very good statement.
Trust yet verify.
And that's if you want to trust our
Dubay that's fine.
But like check,
check the things that he says.
I checked one of his things on the way
here on the plane.
Uh,
he has a thing that a lot of them say,
which is the horizon always rises to a
higher level.
So on the plane,
on the way here,
I checked to see if there was actually
correct.
Now,
most people when they checked to see if
their horizon rises to a level,
they just look out the window and they
say,
Oh yeah,
there's the horizon over there.
I said high level,
but uh,
on the horizon is actually going down a
little bit when you look out the window
of the plane because you're 30,000
feet up in the air.
It actually drops around two or three
degrees,
but it's very hard to see when he was
looking at it out of the window of the
plane.
So it's very easy to get taken into
believing that is that it stays at eye
level.
So what I did is I took this a little
carpenters level.
He brought a carpenter stuck up into
very small one.
It's like this like a inch,
as long as the,
uh,
and I've taped some old tube to the top
which is like a bit of pen and then I
set it level and wedged it so it was
level and then I looked through the tube
on the top of this level and so wide
horizon was and the horizon was just
below the end of a level.
So the horizon,
it actually dropped away,
which meant the debates claim about the
horizon rising to a level which is
something you'd expect on a flight to
earth was actually incorrect and it's
demonstrably incorrect with this $2
level which actually got free from
somewhere and anyone can do this.
You don't even need to be in a plane if
it works better.
If you just like on a cliff or something
like a thousand feet up.
Well that's another claim that people
keep saying that or divo tease this flat
earth idea that that if you get on a
plane and you look up and you look out
the window,
it looks flat.
But I do not think that people
understand perspective and they do not
understand how huge the earth is when
you see there's images,
someone did an image that showed how far
you are up when you're 30,000
feet in the air and then how,
how like huge the earth actually is,
and you get this like little image of a
plane at 30,000
feet and then the dot of the plane is
represented in the,
the amount of distance between the earth
is in perspective.
And then you see how enormous the planet
is and it's just,
you're dealing with something that's so
big.
It's almost,
I mean,
it feels like it's flat.
It feels like it's flat because it's
enormous in your tiny.
Yeah,
that's,
that's a huge issue with people is that
they don't really understand the scale
of the planet and they don't understand
how little it actually curves.
Uh,
those.
There's,
uh,
road.
Uh,
if you look,
if you look up like the longest roads in
America,
longest straight road in America,
there's,
this road is in like Oklahoma or
somewhere and it's about 80 miles long
and it's just perfectly straight.
But it actually isn't perfectly straight
because when they laid it out,
they laid it out along a line of
latitude,
so it's one of the lines that goes
around around the earth.
So it's actually slightly curved.
When you look at it,
it looks perfectly straight.
You have to actually like take their
whole image and then draw a line from
one end to the other in google earth and
you see that it deviates by just these
tiny little amount.
But if you were to drive along this
road,
you're actually driving around.
You're actually turning right slightly
the whole time.
But it looks perfectly straight because
it's hardly moving.
It's old over these 80 miles.
It moves maybe like 10 feet or
something.
And you know,
people just don't,
don't,
don't realize just how small the curve
of the earth actually is.
It looks flat
and again,
I think a real big problem with this
theory and with a lot of these theories,
a lot of these really outlandish
conspiracy theories is once they hook
you,
it's very difficult to unhook yourself.
You,
you don't want to believe that you got
taken.
You don't want to believe he'd been had.
You don't want to believe you've been
fooled,
so you keep going deeper and deeper down
the rabbit hole and you keep finding
more and more confirmation bias.
More people inside that walled garden as
you put it.
Yeah,
and some people actually go out and do
scientific experiments and they try
reasonably hard.
Some of them,
but then they make some kind of mistake
and then they say,
this is actual proof that the earth is
flat.
Like those.
The level experiment that I did,
someone did something similar with that
is that they use like a water level
where you have two tubes connected and
you use the,
the,
the level of the water because the water
level's the same on both of them and
then they hold this up and see if it was
below the horizon.
But they did this experiment and they
did it at sea level,
which meant is always going to be
exactly the same as the horizon.
You've actually got to go up a thousand
feet before you can see anything,
but they still,
you know,
even even though they,
they,
they thought that they were doing some
science,
but they make this one key mistake and
then they weren't listened to anybody
trying to tell them what the mistake
actually was.
A people this a ridiculous amount of
people doing flat earth experiments on
youtube and just getting it completely
wrong.
I think the most common one is people
taking photographs or something that
they shouldn't be visible from a certain
position.
Like they'll say like,
here's a catalina island and it's like
60 miles away and according to the
curvature of the earth,
that means it should been below five
miles of curve.
Uh,
and so it shouldn't be visible.
And then there's all these mistakes that
they make.
Some of them are like,
they,
they do the math wrong.
Some of them,
like they don't account for the fact
that you've got a,
you know,
a,
a factor in how high the viewer is.
Or some of them will just,
they'll get entirely the wrong island.
Like they'll say like,
oh,
this is this island,
which is just layer 100 miles away in
the right.
You're looking at something that's 40
miles away.
Well,
how can we can look out in the.
I mean,
here's a simple one.
How can we look out across the ocean?
You don't see anything on the side.
Yeah.
Like what's over there?
Well,
so far away that you can't see it.
They got an out there.
They're got out though because the,
uh,
you wouldn't get to see anything away
because of the atmosphere.
So thank you.
I'm going to say three things.
Get further away.
They get fainter and fainter islands
that they believe in the atmosphere.
They do and they use it a lot to make up
reasons for certain things like,
like things going on below the horizon
and that's where it gets weird,
right?
It's that people use some science to try
to debunk science or things that they
claim a science,
like the lore of perspective perspective
isn't,
doesn't exist.
There's no law of perspective.
I mean,
if you were to make a lower perspective,
you could say that the size of something
decreases inversely proportional to its
distance,
so if it gets twice as far away,
it's half the size.
If it gets four times as far away,
it's a quarter of the size and that's it
and that's,
that's all that perspective is.
Now.
People talk about vanishing points.
Well,
that came up during the podcast with
Eddie Bravo.
Yeah,
and Jamie brought it up and then Eddie
started posting pictures on his
instagram of a guy from the early 19
hundreds who is an artist who wrote
something about the law perspective in
drawing,
just drawing.
He was just explaining how you,
how you define perspective when you're
illustrating things.
That's,
that's the lower perspective on a piece
of paper,
on a photograph.
It's nothing at all to do with the real
world.
It's about what you can,
what you can see visually,
what the image is projected onto your
eyes or what comes through a camera when
you take a picture,
you know,
what's the actual perspective of things.
You know,
things just get smaller,
but it says it sounds good.
When you say the law perspective,
it sounds good,
like you're invoking a law scientific,
but then they will discuss a real law
like the law of universal gravitation.
Yeah.
I just,
again,
I don't have
anything against Eric do pay or any of
these people.
I really don't.
My real concern is with young people out
there that are listening to this that
get sucked into this stupid shit and
there's a soul much that you could
learn.
There's so much that's fascinating about
the university,
so it's fascinating about the natural
world.
There's so much to learn and to waste
anytime.
The only thing that's good about it is
you'll recognize the pitfalls that the
human mind can slip into that I've
slipped into that many people I know
have slipped into.
And again,
it's not a,
it's not a like in any way,
shape or form.
It's not something to be embarrassed
about or sad about.
It's just,
it's a normal natural human inclination
to try to find things that are hidden
truths or you know,
that are covered up mysteries.
It's natural for whatever reason,
I think it's very much a part of growing
up and I think it's just a,
it's different for different people.
I had a whole bunch of crazy ideas when
I was growing up.
What'd you have a.
I thought I could bring about world
peace by getting a whole bunch of world
leaders together and uh,
I actually sent letters to a bunch of
world leaders and I figured like I
shouldn't send it directly to the world
leaders because there'd be a,
it'll be a bit.
Yeah,
they will want to read my letters.
So I sent it to the brothers.
So I sent a letter to,
to Raul Castro who is now a the
president of Cuba,
but back then I thought,
well I can,
I can set up this organization of the
relatives of world leaders and bringing
about will piece now.
It's that like I was like 13 at the time
that you decided to get ahold of their
brothers.
That's kind of hilarious.
Yeah,
well I think it like a sneaky backdoor.
Yeah.
And I found his address in a WHO's who
in the library back in the day,
back in the day when you look things up
in the library.
Yeah.
I mean,
that's not even that unreasonable.
That's like you thinking,
well,
world piece seems to make sense to me.
This idealistic child,
uh,
and you know,
you want to try to do something and you
think you can,
you think you can make a difference and
you can add rebelling against things.
I had delusions of solving great
mathematical problems when I was young.
Those like,
you know,
problems like how do you try sex and
angle with a by this geometrical methods
which was proved to be impossible to do.
And yet I still spent months and months
trying to do it when I was a kid because
I thought that can't tell me what's
possible and what's not possible.
It seems like it's possible to me.
And if you did discover it,
what a gigantic it would have been
feather in your cap.
That would have been.
That was the motivation really.
It wasn't just like pure altruism.
I wanted to,
I believe in a bunch of stupid shit and
the big one for me that I've clung to
longest has bigfoot.
That one man.
Oh,
it's so hard for me to let that one go
because.
Well,
first of all,
because it used to be an animal,
needs to be gigantic pithy guess,
but man,
when my friend Les Stroud actually
started doing that show,
that bigfoot show,
have you ever seen that show?
And I don't think so.
I did that show with some fucking
guy who's just a total hoax or and the
guy put on a big foot mask and they got
this high resolution photo and video of
this big foot mask that they're claiming
is big foot to staring at them through
the woods.
It is so stupid looking CV and finally
Jamie and this guy,
this is our wacky.
This guy is the bigfoot community.
Thinks he's full of shit.
That's when you know you fucked up when
the big foot community is calling
shenanigans,
they're like,
this guy.
I'm not buying this as spending.
You get these schisms in this community,
so they fracture off into sub
communities.
The scientologists,
there are people who have purchased from
the scientologists watch this.
This is awesome.
See is guys in the woods and he sees it.
He sees it's through the trees.
What is it?
Where is it?
And he can't.
It's not even moving.
Meanwhile,
bigfoot's just been running from people
from day one.
Right?
But there's one animal is just standing
there and he's like,
God,
I think I see it.
I think I said.
So then towards the end of the video,
he gets really close,
like looking at it.
The fuck out of here is Galligan Afro
from the Nineteen Seventies.
Like,
look how clean it's hair looks.
I mean,
it looks so dumb.
It's not moving.
No,
he gets close up on it.
Look at that.
Isn't that wink or something?
Oh yeah.
Here it is.
Look,
look how bad this is bad.
This is.
Here's the this.
Here's how you know it's fake.
Whenever something looks like a dude in
a monkey suit,
it's a dude in a monkey suit.
That's all you need to know because your
brain knows.
Your brain's like,
Hey,
wait a minute.
Like if you look at a gorilla,
gorilla doesn't look like a person in a
gorilla suit.
Feel good a giraffe.
It does not look like a person in draft
suit.
Feel like a big foot and it looks like a
dude in a monkey suit.
It's a fucking dude.
The monkey suit,
like your brain starts filling in the
blanks and also whether you recognize it
or not,
your brain recognize,
recognize geometry.
Facial geometry recognizes a FIBONACCI
sequence.
Hogwash.
Yeah.
And you see,
that's why people freak out when you see
someone fake lips or fake nose upside
down and things like that when,
when people do weird shit to their face,
like when someone,
um,
get the plastic surgery in the face and
they like radically altered their face,
it's jarring to us.
And one of the reasons why it's jarring
is because the brain recognizes geometry
and human facial recognition or facial
patterns and the structure of the face.
And when that geometry is off,
it's confusing to us.
Like why are their cheeks so big?
Why is that?
No so small?
Why are the lips so big?
Like what the fuck is going on?
It's like your body starts to react to
it.
Yeah,
there's an illusion with a put two sets
of eyes on people and you look at that
and you just.
Your brain just is constantly resetting
and you go my eyes across the way or
another.
You frightened just so hard wired to
recognize faces.
Yes.
That it just automatically recognize
faces in your face and my face are
different,
but there's a science to you or the
structure of your face that's applied to
the science.
My face,
and that's the golden ratio.
I mean if you,
if you look at a person's face,
you can actually do the math where their
chin is,
where their eyes are.
It all lines up and your brain
recognizes when that's not the case.
So if you see that and you see like,
oh a person,
what the fuck's
going on?
Because it is a person that's a person
that's a dude in a monkey suit.
It's not even a good one and there's so
many people that tried out that
Patterson footage,
which is so bad.
Yeah,
they,
they believe so hard.
They believe so hard.
It's the hardest one for me to realize
that those people were all full of shit
because when I was a kid,
man,
God,
I don't want a big foot to be real.
That was a,
that was a tough one.
Tough one to let go and plus it was a
real animal at one point in time there
was really a thing called [inaudible],
which was an eight to 10 foot tall,
if it may have been by people at least
occasionally.
Yeah,
yeah,
yeah.
It's A.
Yeah,
you want things to be true like Ufos.
I was going to a Ufo is and all kinds of
weird stuff on it when I was younger and
I think partly like me figuring out the.
A lot of it was just bullshit was part
of the buddy for getting into like
debunking stuff later,
but at a certain degree I think there's
no harm in people believing in things
like you know,
little kids believe in Santa Claus,
etc.
That type of things rather christmas,
easter bunny,
and it's just that for some people it
kind of goes a bit wrong because a bit
too far they don't let the child is
beliefs drop away as they get older or
they stay longer or when they come of
age they go into that kind of the next
level of disbelief,
of imaginary things that they wanted to
be true and a lot of that boils down to
what we're talking about earlier,
the distrust in authority,
like people,
you know,
distrust of others,
and the belief that there's some secret
cabal of people doing things to them.
The illuminati.
Yeah.
So I think it's partly this kind of a
natural,
childish wanting to believe in things
which we all have.
We all believed strange things when we
were young and I think that aliens in a
lot of ways,
they're like a cosmic daddy.
The idea that there's someone who's
really on the ball that's watching us
and you can make sure we don't fuck
everything up.
That's where this content movies are so
popular.
Just the idea of like,
oh,
aliens coming to help us or whatever is
so,
so enticing.
It'd be so amazing.
Yeah.
Meanwhile,
I think the movie alien is probably more
likely.
What's gonna happen?
Just come down here and fuCk us up.
I'm the weird thing about the ufo
community and the big foot community and
all these different communities is that
along the line they become people that
make a living at it and they become,
you know,
air quotes experts and that that becomes
a problem because then they have a
vested interest in making sure that
other people believe they start writing
books,
thEy start doing lectures,
they start showing pictures.
And also here's what's interesting as
the number of phones that have cameras
have radically increased.
The number of usable ufo pictures is
radically decreased.
Yeah.
Which doesn't make sense.
Was like this one got 83 times.
Zoom on it.
You can take pictures of if there was a
ufo,
you can take a real close up picture of
I take patients on planes all the time,
the flying five away or 10 miles away or
sometimes even like,
you know,
every 100 miles away and you can make
out the plane.
You see the windows a.
Yeah,
depending on the angle.
That's the claim that they can trail is
put out sometimes at the planes don't
have windows,
which is generally that a generally
because they using these crappy little
cameras and you just can't see the
windows got the less than one pixel
wide.
Right.
If you've got a good camera and use zoom
in far enough,
the windows appear kind of like,
you know,
things appearing over the horizon when
you zoom in the.
Speaking of this camera,
this suddenly coming up in august,
which is the eclipse,
uh,
there's gonna be a total eclipse of the
sun over north America,
I think August 21st this year.
And I think that's,
that would be a great opportunity for
people to encourage anybody who believes
in the earth to actually start looking
at,
you know,
the what's going on.
Don't they have any excuse for that
though?
He hadn't like how are they,
how are they going to justify it by
eight?
They actually look at it.
I think the challenge is getting people
to look at things.
The excuse the excuse.
The reason we're giving them is that
there's an eclipse and everybody wants
to look at the eclipse because it's an
amazing thing.
The moon goes in front of the sun and
blocks the there.
Yeah,
but I think that you're giving them too
much credit.
I think all someone has to do is make a
youtube video with some wonky
explanation for why an eclipse works and
then it works because the earth is a
disk and the sun gets below the disc and
it blocks it out from below.
I mean,
it just doesn't seem to me that it's.
It's enough.
This is a like a solar eclipse though.
They finished.
They can tell that the moon is going in
front of the sun because I know what
you're saying is logical,
but you know,
even the flight others believed that the
moon goes in front of the sun for a
solar eclipse.
Yeah,
because they can.
You can track the position of the moving
through the sky and they know that,
you know,
he gets closer to the sun every,
every time.
don't they believe that the earth's sits
flat and then everything spins around
the earth.
The earth is flat and the,
uh,
the sun a sun and the moon are orbiting
above like this.
But you know,
sometimes the moon is going to be below
the sun and it blocks out the light of
the sun.
And that's how an eclipse happens on the
earth and on the rounder.
So it will be an amazing thing to see
even if you're a flat earth believer,
this,
this very rare coincidence when the moon
is in front of the sun.
So I usually encourage people who have
flat earth believers to look at this
amazing thing that's happening.
Uh,
they still don't give a fuck.
Is there,
is there a uniformity in the flat earth
community and they like all greed or is
there a dissension?
There's some people say,
you know,
that it's because the ice wall.
No,
there's no fucking ice wall just to drop
off and everybody dies.
There is kind of like,
you know,
this mainstream thing where the dubay
model of things,
it's kind of like in the chem trail
community,
you know,
you've got this one guy,
a dane wigington who's this really
popular guy and then you've got like a
bunch of other patients.
one is he,
is he the guy that made that,
uh,
the videos,
now that was michael.
James murphy was the guy that guy was,
he was a little loony and,
and,
uh,
wigington is the guy who lives in a big
house on 200 acres up in the mountains
somewhere.
And uh,
he got obsessed with the solar panels
being blocked by contractors and so
began the counter,
I'll believe it,
but he,
he's like the equivalent of dubay.
Rarely because he's the guy who was
really promoting it.
But then there's other people in the
country,
the community who are,
uh,
doing their own thing and they say,
yeah,
we can send guy's full of crap because
he believes in global warming and we
don't.
So there's this,
there's this division between people who
believe in global warming and who don't.
So there's some people I think that chem
trials are trying to stop global warming
and other people think that chem trails
are causing global warming.
And then there's other people that think
that's kim kendrick was something
completely different.
This spreading nano robots to control
people's minds and things like that.
You've got the same type of range of
things in the flat earth believers as
well.
Like you.
Some people think that the earth is kind
of concave and it's not actually flat at
all.
What about the hollow earth people?
So the earth is hollow.
That's,
that's not even,
that's not really a flatter thing that's
like around us with a hole in the top
and a whole new world in there.
People live on the inside of the earth,
which makes even less sense than the
data from a physical point of view.
While they think there's monsters in
there.
Yeah.
What were those aliens?
The rothschilds they think their lizard
people.
They live under the earth.
Yeah.
Lasers make tunnels.
You've heard that.
Yeah.
It sounds.
Sounds real.
Yeah.
I'm looking into it.
Any,
any,
any conspiracy theory is going to have a
range of a plausibility.
Yeah.
From reasonably plausible to completely
implausible,
like you think of some of the.
A nine slash 11 conspiracy theories.
Like at one end you've got like the.
The world trade center was destroyed by
nuclear bombs that were in the basement.
Nuclear bombs,
nuclear bombs.
People think that.
Yeah,
I haven't heard that one now.
It's a fringe one,
but it's got a few people who believe
it.
Then there's people who think a bit bit
more plausible.
They were destroyed by energy.
Weapons from space.
Like there was these beams of energy
like high powered microwave or something
that blew the buildings up and then this
know you get more and more plausible.
Those pre planted explosives or some
guys running there on the day with some
explosives to blow building seven,
and then you've got just,
they let buildings haven't burned when
they didn't have to.
And then then they got,
they,
they knew it was going to happen,
but it did nothing about it.
And then they had some warnings about it
and they didn't do anything about it.
So you got this whole range of
plausibility for the conspiracies,
uh,
with the flat earth.
It's pretty much all of this end because
the flush,
her theory is that the earth is flat or
it's round.
So with the flesh of you,
you've only got a very extreme.
And then more extreme theories.
Uh,
some of the most,
the most extreme thing which we,
all conspiracy theories ended up with is
the,
uh,
everything is an illusion.
We're living in the matrix.
A conspiracy theory or that theory is
very compelling that,
that is very bizarre because
one day if technology continues the way
it has been,
there will come a time where they able
to create an artificial reality that's
indiscernible from this reality.
As long as we don't blow ourselves up
and technology continues to advance,
innovation continues to advance at the
rate it is now,
which is exponential,
right?
It's entirely possible that a hundred
years from now or whatever it is,
they'll be some way that they can
interface with your somehow with your
brain and create some sort of an
artificial experience.
Right?
That's not outside the realm of prospect
theory is that doing it now and it's
detectable that these things that we are
seeing,
I kind of artifacts or living in the
matrix,
you might have heard of the mandela
effect.
Yes.
As you know,
the people who believe that this kind of
glitches in the matrix,
like the berenstein bears,
berenstein bears are actually called the
bear steinbeck as a and an alternate
timeline.
Oh,
there was this movie,
a cold shazamm,
uh,
done by.
Well,
I can't remember the guy's name now.
People say sinbad.
Sinbad.
Khazan.
Yeah.
Mixed fleet.
They completely believe that this
actually happened,
but that is,
it is.
It is.
But they believe it.
So that's,
that's something that's at the end of
all,
all these conspiracy theories.
That's not a very reasonable one,
but there's some really reasonable
scientists that believe that there's
going to come a time where the elon
musk.
Yes,
believes that.
Yeah.
I,
I not really convinced myself because
it's kind of a simplistic argument
saying that yeah,
technology will always advance and get
better.
There are fundamental limits on
information theory.
Like how much information that we can
process.
Have you ever messed around with um,
a htc vive or any of the more recent
state of the art?
Now they're mindblowing,
mindblowing.
And this is one of the reasons why I
subscribed to it.
I mean,
not today,
but I mean,
I think one day in the future,
whether there's 100 years or whatever it
is of technology.
I mean,
you just got to think 150 years ago they
were using teletypes to date.
That was the only way to get a medicine
message across,
you know,
um,
and then what can we do today?
We can take a film and send it to
someone in Australia.
They get it in real time.
I think it's very reasonable to assume
that if you put on the htc vive,
they have this one underwater
experience.
It's amazing.
Jamie scene,
if you could find it,
because I know it's in video form,
but I think it's reasonable it on.
There's going to be extremely realistic
things that make you think that you are
there.
Yes,
but I don't think it's realistic that
you would be able to not detect that a
scientist wouldn't be able to detect
that,
that we are all living in a simulation.
Is this simulation just just you?
Is it just your head to see this right
here?
This is.
You put this thing on.
I mean again,
yeah.
We're in 2017 and this is all and it's
fairly fairly adolescent stage and man,
when you're,
when you're in this thing and you're
looking around,
it's not necessarily high definition.
It's,
it's,
it's very clear
and you know that it's not real,
but god,
it gives you this feeling that it's real
and then a whale pulls up and all these
fish swim by.
It's.
It's amazing and it more than anything,
it gives you a window into the future.
It gives you a window when you sit next
to this whale and it makes noises and
the noises are all three d.
It gives you a window when you start
thinking about pong,
remember pong game that you would play.
It was like,
I can't believe I'm controlling
something on the television to to to,
to,
to do it.
Then you compare that to like halo and
the games you can play right now and an
xbox and was like my god,
like the improvements are radical and I
think that the improvements in this sort
of artificial reality,
this virtual reality that you're seeing
in this
current htc vive 100 years from now,
I would only imagine that we could get
to a point where it's indiscernible that
somebody I next to you.
Really.
That's great.
That's why lie.
Look at that.
That whale,
the whale is a living thing.
It's made up of cells.
You could take one cell from that whale
and you could put it under a microscope
and you could dissect it and you could
look at the cell and everything that
say,
okay,
we're having a different argument here.
I'm,
I'm thinking that it's going to feel
real.
You're saying scientists will be great,
I believe.
I believe you won't be able to.
You will be able to.
I don't believe that they could make
something that you could not detect.
I'm not text with science cripple the
cripple your intelligence,
so you're away from it.
They'll be able to make something that's
indiscernible like while you're
experiencing it,
it's like you would a scientist could
come along and check it.
It's a bit of a philosophical question
though because like you know,
what we have now is our observable
universe with the laws of physics.
I don't think within this universe you
could make something that stimulates the
universe that's the same because there's
just too much information in the
universe to be stimulated by something
that is within the universe or even
something like as small as like the the
earth.
I don't think you could simulate the
entire earth in our physical universe,
not now.
You don't think you could do it a
thousand years from now?
Yeah,
really good thing.
So I think there are fundamental limits
as to how much information will be
required.
You could get something that's a,
a,
an imitation of that,
but it will be detectable different.
Like each.
Each simulation is going to be lower
fidelity than the universe that created
it.
Right?
So you can only create something that's
less complex than the universe you have
currently in.
Is that true though?
I mean as time moves on 5,000
years from now,
whatever it is,
I mean,
how could anyone possibly discern or how
could you even guess and estimate how
far it would advance?
You go back 5,000
years ago,
people were modern humans,
you know?
I mean the people that built the
pyramids.
So we're modern humans,
right?
They,
they looked like us.
Maybe a little smaller.
They didn't get as much to eat.
They look just like us.
If you went 5,000
years in the future,
it's not.
It's not unreasonable if we don't blow
ourselves up that you would,
that we would have some sort of quantum
computing,
some astronomically powerful devices
that could render and create an
artificial reality that felt to you
entirely real.
I don'T think that's outside the realm
of possibility,
but could you then create within that
universe the same quantum computers that
are stimulating yourself?
So I think that that's kind of a paradox
really.
It has to be as powerful as the thing
that is simulating it.
I don't think so.
I think artificial intelligence is gonna
lead us to a well,
if You can create something that's
artificial intelligence,
right?
Which we feel like is going to happen
way quicker than 5,000
years from now.
If you create SomethIng that's
artificially intelligent,
it's going to improve upon.
It's designed almost instantaneously.
It's going to realize like if you've
given autonomy.
Yeah.
We don't know what's gonna happen,
right?
Quantum computers.
We don't know how well they're going to
work.
That it could be a dud because could be
fucking amazing.
Could be fucking amazing.
Yeah.
Who knows?
It's something to think about,
but when when scientists start thinking
that we are currently living in some
sort of computer simulation,
I don't discard it.
I'll give it a pause.
I mean I don't,
I don't subscribe or not subscribed to
something as ridiculous as that because
it seems to me within the realm of
future possibility,
yeah,
it's,
it's kind of like it's a thought
experiment because like if we are the
simulation,
we were not going to figure it out when
we're not going to have to do anything
about it if we do figure it out.
Right,
right,
right.
Yeah.
A thought experiment and the scientists
are looking at the laws of physics.
If they keep drilling down far enough,
maybe eventually they'll discover like
the some kind of artificial substrate to
the universe,
which is all ones and zeros and that we
are actually living in some kind of
simulation,
but that's just basically as resolving
the laws of physics and more,
you know,
if we get down that deep,
what can we.
We can't do anything about it.
Well,
not only that,
does that actually mean that we are
living in some sort of an artificial
realm or does it mean that that's what
the universe is made of?
It's not artificial,
but that the universe,
much like what we're creating like that
the universe is almost fractal and much
like what we're creating when we're
creating these artificial environments
at the universe itself is made out of
ones and zeros and then this whole thing
is really mathematical.
Yeah.
And that just because we haven't been
able to detect it up until now,
it doesn't mean it hasn't been running
on some sort of a,
some sort of a uber complicated
mathematical principle.
Yeah.
I think he's kind of a moot point in a
Way because like what's important is
what are the laws of physics and you
know,
can we,
can we detect what's actually running
the laws of physics?
Yeah.
So yeah,
it's,
it's a philosophical question.
What mental masturbating.
Yeah.
It seems to me that that's a thing that
people do,
and I think we could bring it back to
this flat earth thing,
is that people love to go down these
honey holes of of information and have a
debate and ideas and whether it's
bigfoot or ufos,
we love to chase ourselves chasing our
own tail when it comes to these bizarre
subjects
that that may or may not be real and
most likely aren't real.
We love to chase and become like
engrossed in these things and I wonder
why we're doing it.
I wonder if we're distracting ourselves.
you know?
I mean,
it doesn't seem to be people that are
fully happy with their life that really
get into this kind of stuff that really
go all in and balls deep.
You don't.
You don't get a guy who has lIke a
promising career.
He's at the top of his field.
Happy family,
great friends,
great hobbies,
loves his law,
and then it just becomes a ufo and that
doesn't seem to be the case.
Yeah.
You still got these pool players who
believe they're not doing so good.
It's hard out there for a pool player
right now.
The guys at the top of the game is
there,
the teacher,
I think those guys just watched too many
fucking youtube videos and they don't
have any science.
Most of pool players.
One of the things about what's that
common expression about pool players.
if someone plays pool really well,
it's the glorious results of a misspent
youth because it takes a long time to
learn how to play pool really well and
you're not going to be doing that while
you're,
you know,
got your nose buried in physics books.
I think like people like things like
the,
that they,
that they get things out to them,
they're getting something out of it is
giving them purpose in their life.
It's like,
you know,
he's kind of like a hobby in a way.
Like you just doing something because
you enjoy doing it.
Like playing chess.
Yeah.
Except along with that hobby of doing
stuff.
They actually have a belief.
There's is required for them to actually
do their hobby and they don't obviously
think of it like that,
but that's essentially what it is.
They have these activities that they
like doing,
like gardening or whatever,
but it requires them to believe that the
earth is flat,
so they're spending all that time,
uh,
like making youtube videos about how the
earth is flat or doing their experiments
about how the earth is flat and that
they're getting something out of it
because it's the little hobby.
I do The same thing except I'm actually
doing it for science.
Like I do these fun little experiments
like on the,
on the plane today I was on the plane,
like wedged up against the window
looking for,
with this holding my camera up against
it and the woman next to them.
So I thought I was this crazy guy.
You should have told you that the earth
isn't flat,
ma'am.
she probably thought that I was thinking
to the earth was flat.
I've seen other people on youtube that
bringing levels onto the plane and
they're like,
hey,
look for the level isn't moving well if
you work
day and you have an eight hour day plus
commute plus family plus whatever bills
and issues that you have to deal with.
And then you get into one of these
youtube videos,
you simply,
you simply don't have the time to really
explore all of the possibilities and all
the science behind all of the arguments.
and it's just.
Yeah,
I think what happens is either they,
you know,
they get this superficial understanding
of the conspiracy theory,
uh,
or the,
the actual real life suffers.
A lot of people get sucked into
conspiracy theories like,
like chem trails or nine slash 11 truth.
And they become socially isolated and
they become the,
they get divorced and they lose custody
of the children.
Happens all the time.
Yeah.
And this,
this isn't like,
you know,
he's not like the government punishing
them or anything like that.
It just because they become obsessed
with something that is outside of
societal norms and they feel this
overwhelming,
compelling need to tell other people
about it.
Yeah.
And they talk about,
oh yeah,
people roll their eyes when I bring up
the subject of controls or the flat
earth.
And of course they do.
But yeah.
But from their point of view,
they're trying to wake up other people
they're doing,
they're doing the lord's work by giving
the truth to people.
But then there's some theories that are
really compelling,
like when you look into like operation
northwoods and you find out that the
government really was planning false
flag attacks and it didn't work out as
sex saturated.
I now it's not.
How's exaggeration?
Well,
the,
it was a discussion document signed by
the joint chiefs of staff.
Uh,
it's a,
it was rejected by a candidate,
by candidate,
by the joint chiefs of staff very far.
It was just one documents.
They signed it though they got it.
They didn't sign you that they wanted to
do it,
but it was an idea,
the idea that you were going to attack
american civilians,
that you were going to arm cuban
friendlies and attack one tunnel,
that you're going to blow up a drone,
airliner.
These were all proposed things.
They will propose things.
Yeah.
But it was just like,
you know,
but you can understand.
I understand what you're saying,
but spit balling that you're going to
deceive the american people and kill
american civilians,
and then this is a normal part of the
way nero burned rome.
HiTler burned,
burned.
The reichstag that false flag attacks
are real and that they have happened
throughout history.
So when you do have an open mind and you
are compelled to try to seek the truth,
you got to be aware that these things
have happened in history.
They are real and if you dismiss
everything,
you'll be thought of as a shill,
as much as I mean as much as people who
look for conspiracies and everything.
There are also people who try to dismiss
everything and you have to be very
careful because there are a lot of
things that people do conspire to do.
Like one of the things that I brought up
before and people hate when I talk about
this,
but I'm going to do it again.
Uh,
people say I don't believe in conspiracy
conspiracy's.
And I said,
you don't believe in any conspiracies?
No.
Okay.
Do you believe nine slash 11 happened?
I do believe that people flew planes
into jet blue jet planes into buildings.
Well then you believe in conspiracies
because someone can aspire to do that.
And they did it.
They pulled it off.
a bunch of people got together,
decided they were going to attack.
They flew a plane into the pentagon.
They flew two planes into the world
trade center towers.
I mean that really happened.
So that's a conspiracy and they pulled
it off.
So when you debunk all of these things
that are absolutely false,
like flat earth and chem trails and ufo
is and all that Jazz,
you got to be careful to not try to
debunk everything because now people are
saying,
I just think like,
I personally just feel the northwest
thing is a bit overblown.
I don't it what it was.
I think it speaks volumes about what the
mindset of the joint chiefs of staff for
one example.
And a good one though.
Yeah.
But they didn't come up with any others.
Um,
what about what got us into Vietnam?
Gulf of tonkin.
Yeah.
That was a false flag.
Well,
that's debatable too,
because that was just basically they
thought that they were being attacked.
Nothing.
Debatable.
Yeah.
I think that's pretty much been agreed
upon the flag.
It was a series of events led.
There was the,
it didn't happen to over two nights the
report of the boats being fired upon a.
And it turns out that probably wasn't
anything there.
Right.
So it's debatable is,
did they think there was something there
and they wanted to be.
So did they completely invented out of
thin air right now?
Probably used it as a pretext to,
uh,
to uh,
start the Vietnam war.
Uh,
but they just took advantage of it.
learn the same way the bush took
advantage of the nine slash 11 attacks
to push his agenda.
Now,
is that a conspiracy?
It's hard to say like what knowledge did
bush have of the nine slash 11 attacks
beforehand?
We know he took advantage of it and we
know that,
uh,
you know,
the,
uh,
the american administration back then
took advantage of the gulf of tonkin
reports.
We don't know for sure whether the gulf
of tonkin reports were fabricated or how
much they were fabricated or what
actually happened on that night.
Uh,
and uh,
but we do know that they were taken
advantage of.
Yeah.
Well,
uh,
my,
my whole point is that you have to be
careful when you,
a person who debunks things that are
legitimately ridiculous,
that you have to take into consideration
the possibility that people do
conspiring to do things.
Totally.
They do.
Yes.
If that's happened within pretty high
levels of government with enron,
I mean there's this and there's been a
ton of conspiracies that turned out to
be true and that's what they arms very
ryan the Iran contra scandal.
I probably went to all the way to the
top.
Oh yeah.
Reagan probably knew all that.
That was where it was hilarious when it
was,
when reagan was showing the first signs
of alzheimer's,
when he didn't remember,
he didn't remember anything and people
were like,
oh,
he's lying.
And it turns out no,
and he's actuallY memories really
eroding.
The community was an older man.
I Mean,
he's in his late seventies at the time,
wasn't he?
Yeah.
He was a trump sage.
I think jesus christ trump.
There was a fucking hilarious article
about trump today that he doesn't
believe in exercise because he believes
that the body has a finite amount of
energy in it and then when you exercise
you use up that energy and that's why he
has so much energy because he doesn't
exercise.
He has strange diets.
Like he has his steaks.
Well done and he likes to eat lunch meat
straight out of the fridge,
but It's not the head of the show.
Sure.
He's a very nice guy.
Are you never met the guy?
Yeah.
He doesn't look healthy,
but he's got a lot of energy,
man.
Kind of amazing.
How much energy he has.
Alex jones.
Yeah,
he did.
Well,
he kind of looks reasonably healthy.
Guess he's not healthy?
No,
no.
Alex hasn't looked at healthy.
He's overweight and he's,
uh,
he's younger than me.
like I was used to freak out that he's
younger than me.
I was like,
oh,
you're younger than me.
I keep just goes hard.
Alex goes hard all the time,
you know,
and now it takes a toll.
Well,
it's also,
I mean,
constantly worrying that the
government's after you and that there's,
you know,
every fucking turned he take has a
conspiracy behind.
It's the mind can only take so much
pressure.
Yeah.
Cool.
Should we talk about some of flood of
that stuff?
Sure.
What else you get out there?
You've got notes.
I do.
I read everything I could think of on
the fly to which is a shit load of
stuff.
Uh,
the international space station.
Oh,
that's a good one.
Yeah.
I think that that footage is fake.
They think it's all fake,
but what you can do is you guys,
you can get back to the skylab footage
and ask someone who believes in flat
earth how they faked the skyline footage
because this footage of skylight with
people like,
you know,
they're running around and running
around in circles in zero gravity,
as long sequences of people doing stuff
in zero gravity and it's in a space
that's actually too big to fit in any,
any plane that's ever been built.
So it couldn't be filled,
filmed in a thing Where they do the
vomit comet.
Yeah.
It has to be something that was actually
a zero
for people don't know what that is.
When,
when you see scenes in movies where
someone was moving in zero gravity,
they would film that in a plane that
would literally be,
tHey would get the plane up to like
40,000
feet or whatever and then they would
just literally shoot down so that you're
kind of going faster down than gravity
and you could float around.
Yeah.
So this is zero gravity here.
Running around in circles and they do
all kinds of stuff like that.
You get three of them running and this
is the space that they're in.
There is,
is so big that it wouldn't fit in.
Like you probably wouldn't even fit in
the beluga thing that they use for
transporting a planes.
But it ties us back to area 51 because
there's some giant airplanes that they
make an area 51.
They used to simulate zero.
Yeah.
I mean it's obvious that this isn't
space.
Yeah.
And this is like from the seventies.
Yeah,
pretty amazing,
but the space station,
the international space station,
it flies over at regular intervals and
this is not one of the ground truth
things that I was talking about earlier.
You can see it,
you can look up when it's going to fly
over.
You can get them to send you a list.
There's a cycle spot the station as a
nasa site,
uh,
but you don't have to trust it,
but you can still sign up and it will
tell you when the space station is going
to fly over to the second.
He'll tell you to the second one it's
going to appear and how,
how,
how it will be and how long it'll be
visible for.
And you can get to send you an email and
then get your camera out and take
photographs of it when it,
when it happens.
So you know that this website is
correct,
you've proven it on the ground and you
can also do it from different positions
and get two people doing it and you can
figure out how,
how high the space station is by
triangulating acu?
Yeah.
What's the angle?
How far apart they are and you can
figure out that the space station is
actually 250 miles high.
It is orbiting the earth at 250 miles
and you can also take photographs of the
space station with this camera and you
can zoom in close enough on the space
station to actually see the shape of the
space station and the solar panels and
the main modules and everything so you
can see that actually is something that
is moving along the same path that nasa
says is moving along and at the same
speed as they suggest and it's at the
right height and is the right size
because you can do the calculations on
the camera and figure out what the size
of the space station is.
So we know that something that the exact
same size and shape and speed of the
space station is exactly where nasa says
it is.
And there's really no way you could fake
that on a flat earth because you'd have
to have this bizarre.
A thousand foot wide a floating thing
moving along at like 14,000
miles an hour.
Doing this kind of whizzy pattern all
around this spiral graph pattern around
the flat earth.
It's Just.
It's literally impossible.
Whereas if you'd look at it from the
globe model point of view,
it's just the space station orbiting the
globe,
but does this bother you?
Sometimes you're even debunking the
staff,
do it,
does it?
Does I catch myself and go,
fuck,
am I doing?
Yeah,
it's obviously,
yeah.
One of the most stupidly obvious proofs
that were not on the flatter is that if
you get three people yesterday,
standard,
one of them or the bottom of South
Africa,
one of them at the bottom of south
America and one of them in Australia and
have them all look south from that
position.
Now on the flat earth,
you got one person here,
one person here,
and if the old south like away from the
north pole,
they're all looking in completely
different directions,
but in the real world,
what do they actually see?
The lcd,
the exact same constellation,
the southern cross right in front of
them,
so they're all looking in different
directions on the flood earth,
but on the round earth,
they're all just looking towards the
southern cross.
So see what you're sayIng.
It's literally impossible to do that on
the flat earth and you can actually see
this and take photographs of the
constellations and compare.
And that's something I was talking about
with the ground truth thing with
malaria.
And like you can,
you could go virtually yourself to these
places and see what the sky looks from
that position.
Uh,
so either solarium is lying or these,
you know,
the southern cross does actually appear
from these three different positions.
Well that's another thing that these
flatters people keep bringing up as
polaris.
The idea that this one star puts a great
one and that all these other stars
rotate aroUnd it and that this is
somehow or another proof that they're
not spinning.
What are there?
We're on a flat earth.
What's so stupid about that is that
people in Australia have a completely
different constellations and the stars
rotate the other direction around from
the start.
They're all coming towards us from the
east.
So if you look north,
they're going that way.
If you look south the going that way.
So the rotating around the north star,
which actually isn't anything special,
it's just the stuff that happens to be
closest to the point,
the north point,
and it changes all the time.
If you zoom in,
you can actually see there are stars
that are even closer and if you take a
time lapse of the north star,
it actually makes a little circle.
But,
and also that north star is not the same
north star is in the past because the
axis of the earth,
uh,
there's this thing called procession
where they,
uh,
every 26,000
years and wobbles away.
Yeah.
But yeah,
the south,
the south team,
everyone's looking at the same thing in
the south and the stars are rotating in
that direction.
But yeah,
polaris,
polaris is a good one for a number of
reasons.
One is not really fixed.
It's one degree off from the center of
the celestial sphere,
but if you look at a time lapse
photograph of the earth,
if they point a camera up like say from
north America,
what you get is the illusion that all
these stars are spinning around that one
star.
It's fixed,
but it's because you're looking at a
time lapse of only a few hours where
it's dark at night.
Whereas this procession of the equinoxes
is a very slow process that takes 26,000
years and you're just not going to get a
26,000
years time lapse photo of you could
simulate it.
You could still area.
And I was going to believe that.
What's interesting is that some
cultures,
it's been pretty much observed that some
cultures were aware of.
The procession of the equinox is
thousands of years ago.
Somehow that they kind of knew,
you know,
quite impressive.
It will.
A lot of old coaches did actually take
records of the stars because stars we
used for navigation.
Yeah.
Uh,
the post,
you know,
obviously is something that gives you,
this fixed north a degree,
but the other stars as well,
like if you know,
you know what,
how long it takes to go from one place
to another.
You don't really understand the exact
math,
but you can use it for navigation.
It's called celestial navigation.
What other ridiculous things can we
point out before we wrap this up?
My head's starting to hurt.
I had food poisoning yesterday,
folks.
I don't know what happened.
I ate something bad at a greasy diner.
Well,
polaris is a good thing because you can
actually look at the angle of polaris
was at a bang.
Do you hear banging?
I heard banging.
Oh,
it's next door.
He is putting something on the wall.
It sounds like they shut down the stream
twice on us already.
Oh really?
Yeah,
it's flat earth.
I'm recording the whole thing.
God dammit.
Um,
what are the things that were they to
us,
the others wonder why they.
Earth's atmosphere isn't sucked off into
space.
Uh,
well,
how about the one where that's a good
one,
but it's a good one because I've
wondered that myself.
I know now why,
why that is.
I know why it's such going to get stuck
in this space because you think you
think that a vacuum sucks things,
right?
It's going to suck.
Everything sucks everything away.
So if there's this atmosphere on the
earth,
the vacuum of space suck it away.
But the thing is like vacuum doesn't
actually suck.
Vacuum is nothing.
He has no energy.
It doesn't do anything.
There's no power.
The reason that things flow into vacuum
is air pressure and air pressure as a
function of gravity.
So gravity is pulling everything down
towards the earth.
So there's no,
there's no nothing that can push it out.
If you see.
You see what I'm saying?
If,
if you imagine like if the universe was
suddenly filled with loads and loads of
gas like oxygen.
So.
And then you stick a big planet in the,
all the gas would kind of like gravity
would bring it down towards this planet.
Will they don't believe in gravity.
Electromagnetic.
This is my favorite new one.
Didn't see the font one.
Whether they show that if the earth was
a globe,
that all the water would be on the
bottom.
Yeah.
That's wonderful.
I think that was a joke.
It's a joke.
How?
How can you show?
What about the other ones as well,
but.
No,
no,
no.
Bring it up.
Jamie.
This one's wonderful.
I think they're being serious.
Yeah.
Now the gravity thing though,
it's kind of like almost irrelevant
because yeah,
we know that things fall down,
right,
but it's electromagnetic something or
another.
Well,
it's magic.
It's a magical force that's making
things hold down.
It doesn't really matter.
You know?
Gravity.
We could say we don't really understand
what gravitates lava lava as part of
gravity to write lava.
Well,
it's the idea that all these rocks are
pushing down and there's extreme heat
and buoyancy,
buoyancy and density and density.
The functions of gravitate,
like if you stick something in the
water,
it's all the water is flowing into the
bottom.
This we're looking at this image folks.
It says gravity is not strong enough to
stop a small stream from flowing to its
lowest point.
Then what is stopping the oceans north
of the equator from emptying into the
ocean south of the equator.
This is what the earth would look like
if we lived on a globe.
Gravity is pseudo science,
dot,
dot a theory that can't be proven.
They forgot the apostrophe and can't you
fucking don't look at that image though.
It's hilarious.
Why is there water on the top at all?
How about that?
You stupid.
Fuck it's raining.
It rains on top.
Only separates from the bottom and comes
around.
I'll would be kinda cool if half the
planet was dirt and have plant was
watering word,
whether that be any weirder than what it
is now.
You know the reason they didn't like
gravity is that if you actually apply
the lows that gravitates to a flooded
flooded with actually scrunch up into a
bowl.
Oh,
okay.
Oh yeah.
Right.
There's no way it can.
It can lay flat.
It would.
It would either be like gravity.
It would be an intensely lodge because
you've got an infinite abundance of rock
underneath.
Yeah.
Or it's like something on the back of a
turtle or something and it will just
scrunched up into a bowl.
What do they think?
Lava is?
Molten rock.
I mean they just think it's brilliant
because it heats up and becomes less
dense than the other rock.
Why is it?
Why is it down there?
And the bottom was a core of the fires
of hell.
A heating it up.
The fires of hell.
Look at this.
What is this?
Tennis ball?
Why doesn't water fly off the earth
spins because the,
this for suspending this is a,
this is a fundamental misunderstanding
that they will have.
They,
they,
uh,
misinterpret angular velocity and linear
velocity.
Like we know the earth is spinning
around a thousand miles an hour,
right?
They think if this bowl was spinning
around at a thousand miles an hour,
then the water would,
would,
would fly off.
But it's not flying off because of the
surface of the bowl going a thousand
miles an hour,
it's flying off because it's rotating it
like 50 times a second or whatever,
and 10 times a second,
it's the angular velocity which creates
the outward force.
Linear plots has got nothing to do with
it.
He's anyone.
You're actually turning,
you know when you're driving in a car,
like you'd be driving really,
really fast.
You didn't really feel any forces act on
you,
but when you go around the corner,
you get slumped over to one side.
So it's the the rate of your angular
velocity.
Now the earth rotates once,
once every 24 hours.
So it's going really,
really,
really slow.
Put that back up please.
And if you imagine that tennis ball,
and if you take it and stick in a little
turntable,
the rotates,
once every 24 hours,
the water is not going to fly off.
And it's the exact same force acting on
the earth because the earth rotates once
every 24 hours.
The fact that it's like you're going a
thousand miles an hour,
it's completely irrelevant because it's
essentially going in straight lines
around the edge.
Jamie,
go to that photo on the upper left hand
side.
Scroll up
satan's globe earth like this.
This,
this bottom picture here is a great
example of how ridiculous things are.
It's hold on
satan's globe earth lied.
The big bang and evolution.
Explain life.
You were an accident.
We evolved from primordial soup.
We are specs in the universe.
Some people are more valuable than
others.
Foundation for the new world order you
are worthless.
Next image.
God's flat earth creation is the only
explanation.
We are incredibly valuable.
The bible is 100 percent true.
We live on an unmoving firm foundation.
You were created by god in all caps.
God loves you and that that
seems better.
That's probably a true believer.
The oh yeah.
You think that image there is a is a
good example of things that are just
completely ridiculous on the flutter
earth.
You see they have the sun on one side
and it's eliminating healthier and the
way,
the way it's cooked like that.
The thing that runs way closer to.
Right?
Yeah.
They think the.
The son acted like a spotlight.
He's looking at that.
It's not like a spotlight is
illuminating all of the ice wall.
Where's the ice wall?
That's the white stuff,
right?
Yeah.
Oh yeah.
Which is actually.
It's just a antarctica stretched into
this projection.
Why doesn't one of those dickheads
getting a boat and take a photo that
wall?
Well,
that's another thing.
They think they'll go god's all the way
around it.
Oh,
there are guards.
Yeah.
That's a.
What is that?
That's true for like 36,000
miles of guards of gods in the ocean
with on a freezing ice
wall.
Is the wall from it.
Game of thrones is that 36,000
miles.
They make up facts and then they use
those facts to kind of stayed there.
Point like you can't.
It's illegal to fly over antarctica.
Yeah.
That's kind of based on like half.
Well a quarter truth like you have to
have.
You can't fly to engine jet over
antarctica because if an engine fails
you wouldn't be able to get to an
airport.
So they only allow a four engine jets,
seven,
four,
zero,
eight,
three eight is to fly.
So all those,
those flights that you see that go over
at the antarctic ice,
they're all seven,
four,
seven.
Yeah.
Because if it fucks up your doomed.
it's a long way with nothing because set
of regulations called itar,
which is all about how far you can go
away from an airport and what
configuration of plane that you have to
do.
See now I wonder how many people are
listening to this and it's turning their
mind.
Do you think it's possible?
Do you think there's.
There's gotta be a spectrum of people
that believe there is a spectrum and
some people will,
will be turned.
This will cause a lot of ruffled
feathers.
Are you ready for the shill tweets?
Are you ready?
Well,
you were around her.
She'll shirt if we get you one and
jamie.com.
I actually done like.
It's very complicated.
I know it's all,
it's all in good humor.
Soft people like joking around,
but take it seriously.
Oh yeah.
With that said,
I make stuff up that my wife got me
because I'm always making stupid jokes.
Right.
And someone saw a photograph of me
online wearing this tee shirt that said
I make stuff up and says make west.
I'd missing a completely serious.
Yeah.
But there stupid.
Um,
yeah,
but it's part of the mesa to reach
people if,
uh,
if,
you know the,
the pointing the been,
it's a distraction,
right?
Something like that.
Yeah.
I guess I guess I hear what you're
saying.
I'm pretty easy to dismiss.
Um,
they always say that you work for the
government.
That's the big one.
you're a government employee.
You made video games,
video game programmer.
I helped make the tony hawk series of
video games and made enough money to
retire on.
And now I just pushed her around the
house.
Do gardening and do a debunking stuff.
Do fun experiments in the village.
You live in the goddamn american dream.
It's where you're doing.
You made enough money to not have to
slave away.
And these assholes who want to think
that you're some government shill,
like the governments involved in the
tony hawk video games.
They recruited you.
They said,
listen,
I know you're doing a good job making
these video games.
We've got a better place for you.
I need to do is cover up the flat earth
and chem trails and you have photos.
And what else?
What else you cover up?
Morgellons.
Morgellons disease is a fascinating one.
It's one of the ones that we introduced
that we investigated on that show.
And do you know that one of the guys
that we interviewed was a doctor and
what he thinks is that everyone who has
more gallons also has lyme disease and
lyme disease has a neuro toxicity
effect.
And he was talking to himself about his
own hallucinations that he sees things
like crawling crosses eyes that he knows
aren't there.
Oh yeah.
He was a very rational and he
was also saying that lyme disease,
when you get it from ticks,
that you're not just getting this one
disease,
but you're getting a host of pathogens
and sometimes these pathogens will
interact with each other.
In very different ways and that you
know,
some are more extreme,
some are less extreme,
but he's like you might be dealing with
hundreds of different pathogens that are
an undiscovered or are undefined and he
thinks that what's going on with a lot
of these people that have more jealous
is lyme disease and whatever these other
diseases are that's causing them to
hallucinate and think that fibers are
growing out of their skin would really.
What it is is they're scratching
themselves and then they get like carpet
fibers or clothing fibers on their skin
and then they think it's coming out of
there.
He was very reasonable and he made a ton
of sense because we went to this more
jealous convention and we talked to all
these people that had it and they
fucking all have lyme disease.
They all have it.
Well,
they'll.
They'll get tested positive for it.
That's a bit of controversy about that
because the test that you can do,
you can basically keep doing it and it's
kind of a very inexact test for lyme
disease and it gives a lot of false
positives.
There's a bunch of different tests,
but there's so many people
with lyme disease,
which is where it's interesting because
lyme diseases,
it's.
I know a lot of people that have gotten
it from ticks and it's fair
thing.
It's a real thing that's devastating.
There's a lot of controversy.
Well,
yeah.
It's one of those things that the
medical community as a mainstream
opinion about whether the longterm
effects from lyme disease and then
there's people who think that there is
the longterm effects,
so there's some dispute.
There is some.
Let me clArify from people that I know
that have gotten it.
One of the things about the medical
community is the ignorance of the of
lyme disease and that you go to a lot of
different doctors and they.
They poo poo it.
They say,
oh,
this is nothing to worry about.
My friend's son got it and he developed
bell palsy,
bell's palsy.
His face went numb and that was when
they took it seriously and they finally
gave him this intense round of
intravenous antibiotics,
but my friend was on antibiotics for
months.
I mean,
he was devastated and we had a guy in
here that had it for three years and he
had it for a full year where he was
undying.
Steven kotler it a full year where,
who's undiagnosed?
And his body just was ravaged
by this stuff.
Well,
I used to do write a lot about
morgellons,
which is related to lyme disease.
And one of the reasons I stopped doing
it was the,
it's such a personal thing for the
people involved,
uh,
and I just really wasn't comfortable
like calling them liars.
Not that,
but just trying to,
trying to figure out what's really going
on and raising possibilities that it
might not be like these bugs living
under their skin because they just get
very upset and you,
you really,
you weren't reaching a lot of them.
So eventually I stopped that and I moved
on to chem trails,
which I thought would be a more
reasonable people involved.
But uh,
it's another one where people or
initially invested in that idea.
And then once they become initially
invested,
it's so hard to shake them off.
It's so hard.
They just are absolutely convinced that
the government is spraying things.
So yeah,
I had a conversation with a friend of
mine.
I was like,
dad has got to be the most ineffective
use of money ever.
like they're spraying things and what
the fuck has changed?
Nothing.
Nothing's changed.
They're spending all this money spraying
things in the sky that just happened to
look like clouds,
but yet we know that you can make clouds
with a jet engine and a certain amount
of condensation in the atmosphere.
The heat of the jet engine causes
clouds.
Like we know that,
but they don't think that's what
it is.
Yeah.
This is established science established
nine.
Well,
like,
you know,
the flood earth is just steadily.
The lack of flatness of the earth is
established science that's been going on
for a real long time.
Uh,
and people just pick and choose which
science they went to to you.
What keeps you going with all this stuff
for the running metal bunk?
Well,
I,
I enjoy like doing this little little
experiments.
Uh,
I do a lot of stuff like,
you know,
going into my backyard and testing
things out,
uh,
like a lot of this stuff you,
there's pictures of ufo was and things
like that and you can,
you can duplicate them because some of
them are like,
like reflections or things in the
canberra and yoU can go out and say,
well,
this did this.
Or people are saying that certain
photograph is a indication that it's
false or these shadows go this way.
You know,
the moon landing has lots of fake shadow
claims made about it.
What do you think happened at roswell,
New Mexico?
the one that's the big one,
July,
1947.
A ufo crash.
Yeah.
I think it's what the,
what it said it was,
it was,
uh,
that uh,
those balloons that they were using to
detect a russian nuclear bombs in the
atmosphere.
And it was a secret program so they
weren't allowed to tell anybody about
it.
So they came in,
they picked up the remains of the
balloon and then the story just took
off.
That's a funnY one though.
Boy,
that's,
that's made a whole town.
Yeah.
Famous for ufo,
if you go there noW,
they have like alien themed gift shop,
so the milking it and it's like you said
earlier,
like people make money out of something
and then they get stuck into that just
because they're making money out of it.
They're motivated to promote whatever it
is,
a big foot or if it's aliens.
Have you ever seen anything and all of
your years of trying to debunk these
things that made you question whether or
not this was a legitimate phenomena,
the chem trail,
anything?
Anything,
anything.
Bufo chem trail thing.
It's like with ufo.
There's all things that you can't
explain.
There are things that are identified,
but there are usually plausible
explanations for them.
I like to,
whenever I'm given something that can be
mysterious thing,
I like to list all the explanations that
I can think of and maybe none of them
are a perfect fix that fits that you can
guarantee this is what the explanation
is,
but like it being like a ghost or an
alien spacecraft as an explanation is
usually pretty close to the bottom.
Like you started out saying,
oh,
it's a balloon or a bird,
or it's a drone or at cgi or it's
something,
something somebody faked afterWards,
or it's an alien spacecraft or in
between that like always something else
that we don't know what it is.
Is there any evidence like in terms of
ufo?
That's interesting.
I haven't to be honest,
I haven't really looked into the,
the whole sphere of ufo biology.
Uh,
I know a lot of people have,
but just looking at the quality of the
best cases they put forward.
Like I mentioned earlier,
like you know,
some guy in 1964,
like got his car beat up on a road a,
these are like the top 10 best cases.
And this was like number two or
something.
What about bob?
LiZ,
are you ever looking at that guy and ah,
which was he as the guy who supposedly
know,
supposedly worked at area 51 and became
a whistle blower.
no,
I haven't,
but a lot.
It's something You see.
And the nine slash 11 community is.
and in the chem trail community is
people kind of becoming celebrities.
Yeah.
And then they kind of start going on
road shows and you know,
they go to conventions and they speak
and then they write books and then they
start doing things and they,
they get sucked into the,
the,
the beliefs.
And there's been lots of examples in the
past of people who made claims like
this.
And then eventually,
uh,
you know,
owned up to it,
the classic one really classic one is
the cost tingly fair is where these
girls and continually england sound I
went to school in,
but it's still world famous thing,
a fake these photographs of fairies.
And they,
they convinced a large number of people
in including,
like arthur conan doyle,
a really guy wrote tarzan.
Yeah.
He believed in fairies.
Well,
no,
the guy who wrote sherlock holmes did
arthUr conan doyle,
right.
Turns out that was a william burroughs
and I went,
no,
someone else.
Anyway,
but they look at that.
They stuck to that.
So they obviously fake out of a magazine
or something.
Uh,
and then they owned up like basically on
their deathbeds live 70 years later.
But they were,
they were milking it because once they
get into it is embarrassing to admit
that you made something up,
plus you're getting all this attention.
Right.
And in some cases you're getting money.
I don't know if they get any money and I
wonder how many people were so duped by
that,
that changed their life and they started
looking for ferries and wasting their
time when I was growing up.
That was,
that was put out as being a genuine
fairy citing.
Really?
Yeah.
And you believe it?
Pull them?
No.
Well I probably did when I was like,
you know,
13.
Oh six people.
People get sucked in and they become
celebrities.
Uh,
and then they like,
there it is.
Yeah.
Tna reveals the fIrst time letter which
ended the cotton hundley pleasingly
here.
Emily hoax.
Yeah.
I went to school,
just retail,
just behind the house.
So for 70 years this lady kept lie.
Yeah.
there was two of them I think what bitch
and people like that in the ufo
community who like made up stories of
abductions and things.
And then later the stories either become
so ridiculous and contradictory.
You know that they were lying.
There's a wonderful one from this guy
from the 19 fifties where it's a great
old black
and white footage and they talked to him
about his ufo experiences and all the
different aliens that he communicates
with and he just seems so obviously
crazy and yet this was heralded as one
of the most important cases of ufr log
and you know,
the guy I'm talking about,
I forget the guy's now as many.
There was a thing called hubcaps and
shit.
The montauk chronicles,
which I think you would do the segments
on that.
it was like an island where they have an
underground thing where they really
meant to be experimenting on children.
Plum island wasn't plum island.
Anyway,
there was,
there was something like that.
This guy basically said he had all these
remembered memories of working on this
secret government base.
Uh,
and he became like pretty famous.
You'd read loads of books,
but I think he might have just been a
bit crazy.
But.
well,
there's a lot of that out there for
sure.
Is there anything else in your pile of
notes over there to get people to?
I think the thing I would really
encourage people to do is look closely
at things like it's really hard to do,
but if people who are on the fence,
they they need to look very,
very closely at the claims that people
are making claims that the bay is
making.
If eric debase say something like,
you know,
the horizon always rises to eye level.
This is something you can actually check
and it's not easy.
He got to be reasonably careful with us
$2 level,
but you can actually check to see
whether that is correct.
You can check for yourself if something
reappears over the horizon when you zoom
in and which is something that he
claimed,
something that as ridiculous claim that
has been made for like over a hundred
years that when things move away from
you,
they disappear from the bottom up and if
you zoom in,
they will reappear.
He doesn't actually happen.
When you zoom in on something,
all it does is it makes the picture
bigger.
It makes the image bigger and you can
check this for yourself.
You can go down to santa monica pier,
you can focus on like the north shore
like malibu,
and you can zoom in and you can see the
picture does not change at all
throughout the entire zone and when
you're fully zoomed in so you can see
the cars whizzing along,
pca,
you will see that the bottom part of,
uh,
of,
of the road is,
and the buildings are obscured and you
can do it with catalina.
You can turn around and look at catalina
and you can zoom in on that and you can
see that two thirds of catalina island
is missing.
I think a lot of what you're saying is
very important because what we're
talking about is just being able to look
at things objectively and use facts to
determine that this one theory in
particular flatter theory is not true.
But I think what's really going on is
the thought process.
There is a way the human mind gravitates
towards these puzzles and these problems
and these,
these undiscovered truths,
these,
these mysteries that people just want to
be the person that knows they want to be
in the know and it's very intoxicating
and that's what really this stuff's all
about more than anything.
It's about the way the mind works and
about the way your mind can be tricked
and it's an information issue that we're
dealing with today with things like
youtube where no one can stop you from
making like you don't have to go through
the people that work at nbc or fox or
whatever.
You'd have to go through the wall street
journal or the New York times editorial
board where they have to review your
paper and go,
hey,
you wrote a bunch of stuff.
ThAt's not true.
That doesn't have to happen anYmore.
Now you can just make a video and it can
be really well done with good music and
good images and the way it's done can
really influence a lot of people who
don't have a background in science or
not curious about looking into the
debunking version.
Of it,
whenever,
when someone sends me something,
I always say,
just google that whatever you sent me
and then debunked,
just do that first and then look at both
sides,
you know?
But people don't want that.
debunk that debunks not sexy.
Yeah.
That's pretty sexy.
I know people are turned off by the
debunking thing.
I hate it.
Yeah,
and that's why I do tell people to go do
their own research,
but really actually do some real
research as in do some actual
observations and experiment.
Boring.
Youtube videos are fun.
You know,
you watch a youtube video about
dinosaurs being faked.
That's fun.
What?
They're fake.
I can't believe it.
They fucking got me.
Just like watching a youtube video about
roswell rods or any of these other silly
things and kind of excited about the
eclipse.
I think that's an opportunity to get
people excited about a scientist though.
Not thinking like a loon.
I know like I get excited about the
eclipse,
but not everyone does.
Well,
it's exciting.
It is exciting.
It's pretty rare.
Solar eclipse.
The moon is going to come of the sun.
Yeah.
Get your camera.
What does that happen?
Check it.
August 21st.
It's going to be totality in Oregon,
but you had to see it from all of a lot
of people going to go to Oregon just to
see it.
Yeah,
I'm going to Oregon.
Are you?
Wow.
Look at you.
You don't fuck around type relative.
So it an excuse.
They're going to try to schedule some
sort of a dinner time.
They,
we're going to be out of the campsite.
Yeah.
Looking at the eclipse.
um,
anything else?
And I saw the same.
oh,
uh,
and it's kind of complicated,
but let me just run right by you real
quick.
maps,
and you hit the maketa projection.
No,
the standard map that you see in school
rooms has this really stretched out.
Iceland,
greenland,
it looks like kind of distorted.
It's not like the real world.
And the reason that we use these maps,
this particular type of map is that if
you draw a line between two points on
the map,
uh,
and then you sail along that heading,
you will end up at that point.
Now this,
uh,
this is a type of navigation called a
rum line navigation that's been used for
like hundreds of years,
and the thing is that the map,
the makeda matt gets stretched out to
the top but also get stretched out at
the bottom because the navigators have
from hundreds of years ago knew that the
world was round and that they knew if
they drew a line between two points in
the southern hemisphere using the same
map,
it would get you to that destination
using rum navigation,
which is basically just one more piece
of evidence.
That's the actual,
the global map matches reality because
people have used rum navigation for
hundreds of years,
if not thousands of years.
So you're saying that the image of the
continents is in some way stretched out
and distorted?
Yeah.
Well,
if you take a glider,
they do that.
We will.
If you take a globe and like just,
you can't just put it onto a flat
surface,
right?
Because you're gonna have to distort it
somehow.
Uh,
so there's various different ways people
use of,
of,
of putting it on,
on the surface.
You could just take,
you know,
you love to do to longitude and just map
it into a rectangle and that,
that works out fairly well.
that's a nice thing that's called
equirectangular map,
but the most common map that was used
like before,
like say 30 years ago was this maketa
projection,
which is the map that people use.
Navigating ship routes.
So you can get from point a to b if you
wanted to go from england to,
uh,
you know,
north America across the ocean,
you just draw a line between the two
points and then you say,
oh,
that's the heading I've got to go in.
And so you head off in that heading.
Now that doesn't take you in a straight
line.
It actually takes you into kind of a
curved line because if you,
if you're going on a constant compass
heading on a globe,
you actually kind of curve in towards
the poles or away from the pole
depending which way you're going.
I really don't understand what you're
saying,
but all it is,
is that this method of navigation that
people use that relies upon the earth
being a globe.
And it's this really,
really simple map that is in thousands
of homes,
millions of homes and schools that
everybody uses,
and you can see that on the map,
the lines get smaller towards the top
and it gets more towards the bottom.
And if people are doing,
uh,
a voyage around the world,
they're going to use this map and it
only works on,
it works on there around the globe
world.
That's another issue too.
People have circumnavigated the globe.
Yeah.
Well they think they do sail around the
outside,
which of course would take a lot longer.
Uh,
that's another thing like the Australia.
Have you seen Australia on the flood
earth map?
It's like a no on the image that was up
earlier.
It's like this kind of squish thing,
you know,
where to Australia it looks like it's
more or less like,
this looks like it's kind of like this,
it's all stretched out.
It's like twice as long and half as
wide.
Have you seen the theory,
the conspiracy theory that Australia is
scooby doo a?
No.
Give it to his head.
Yes.
Yeah,
I can say that it's just a joke.
Italy as a boot.
Yeah.
They just.
It's one of those joke names.
The distances between places in
Australia don't work.
Is that the flatter?
Yeah.
that's the flat earth map and that's
Australia and Australia.
It looks nothing like that and if you
live in Australia you would know it
looks nothing at all like that.
It's just hilarious that there's so many
versions of this similarity.
There's so many people who've taken the
time in front of a computer to create
this flat earth map and put this ice
wall and the idea that.
How do they know?
It's a nice wall.
Like where?
Where's the pictures?
There's pictures of ice shelves from
antarctica,
so they think that that's the whole
wall.
I think that's the wool.
Yeah,
so that you'll see memes like,
yeah,
globally what?
Flat ice wall and they'd be like this
and they show you.
they suck on an ice shelf,
which is like 200 feet high.
What'd you could fly over?
That's the mentality,
right?
It's a bunch of little kids or a bunch
of dumb people or a bunch of people that
have very little education or a bunch of
people that are also speaking.
They're preaching to the choir.
It ties into like a misconception.
Is that a natural,
like a funny thing like when I worked in
the video game industry,
there was a platform games.
You jumped from little platforms and
some of the times the platforms and move
around and like mario type things,
right?
Uh,
in some video games when you jump up on
a moving platform and then jumped down
and fall down,
you will fall down because the platform
moves out from underneath you.
Sometimes you jump up and you move with
the platform and you land on it.
It depends on what the program did.
Right now a friend of mine was doing a
video game and I wanted the program and
said like,
oh,
he jumped up and then jump down.
The platform should have moved out from
underneath you.
So you should be able to like,
hey,
you should be able to,
uh,
you know,
this is the way we should program the
physics.
And then my friend matt said,
no,
that's wrong.
And uh,
he couldn't convince this other guy.
So eventually what happened?
He says,
right,
what we're going to do is we're going to
go out onto the road with my pickup,
my pickup truck,
I'm going to get in the back and you're
going to drive along at 30 miles an hour
and I'm going to jump straight up in the
air and we're going to see whether I
land in the truck or a land on the road.
So they did this experiment and the guy,
the other guy who was driving the truck
was totally expecting him to like jump
up and pull out the back of the truck
because the truck went and moved on
because he's moving the same speed as
the truck.
So he jumps up and then he lands back in
the tRuck.
And this,
that.
This is illustrating that this video
game program,
I had the exact same misconception that
the flat earth is due because they say,
well,
what if the earth is moving so fast?
Why can't you just go up in a
helicopter,
hover a bit,
wait for the earth to move underneath
you,
and then go back down again.
It's just,
you know,
it's completely backwards physics
because you are already moving,
so you'd have to slow down to zero a
which is the same as speeding up and
relatively speaking.
So,
uh,
the point is that anyone can make
misconceptions about physics like that.
Yeah.
And it's easy to get sucked into that
and it's actually quite hard to break
them even play.
This is reasonable guy.
It was like a video game program,
but who presumably knew something about
physics.
He was convinced that matt was going to
fall out to the back of the truck and
quite possibly die,
but he still didn't do the experiment.
Well,
let's end it on that because this is
literally hurting my brain,
right?
But what you're doing is very important
and I really want to thank you.
Thank you.
Your website is very important.
It's very important for people who are
curious and concerned and don't
understand the physics and the logic and
the science behind it all,
but I've.
I've sent your site to many,
many people that believed or don't
believe and we're trying to figure out a
way to explain it,
so thank you.
Thank you.
Thanks for being.
All right folks,
that's it for the week.
Syria.